PLEASE SILENCER CELL PHONES.
THANK YOU.
>>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
SILENCE YOUR CELL PHONES.
THANK YOU.
>>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THIS IS THE
WEEK OF COLUMBIA AND WE ARE
PRIVILEGED TO WELCOME
PRESIDENTS, PRIME MINISTERS AND
GLOBAL POLICYMAKERS TO CAMPUS.
EACH OF THEM A WORLD LEADER WHO
COMSAR TO EXPRESS HIS/HER VIEWS
AND TO ENGAGE OUR STUDENTS
DIRECTLY ON THE MOST PRESSING
ISSUES FACING SOCIETIES.
FOR SEVERAL REASONS THIS
PARTICULAR COLUMBIA WORLD
LEADERS FORUM STANDS OUT ON THE
CALENDAR AND CARRIES VERY
SPECIAL SIGNIFICANCE FOR OUR
UNIVERSITY COMMUNITY.
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE ARE VERY
HAPPY TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HEAR FROM DR.TEDROS WHO
BECAME THE DIRECTOR GENERAL OF
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
IN JULY.
IN ADDITION TO WELCOMING YOU TO
COLUMBIA DR.TEDROS , WE OFFER
YOU OUR CONGRATULATIONS AND
BEST WISHES FOR YOU AS YOU
BEGIN YOUR TERM AS DIRECTOR
GENERAL.
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ADDRESSING THE
MOST SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH
CHALLENGES FACING HUMANITY.
FROM EMERGING PANDEMICS,
ANTIBIOTIC RESISTANT INFECTIONS
TO THE HEALTH EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
INDEED, THESE MATTERS HAVE FOR
SOME TIME OCCUPIED FOCUS, AND
ATTENTION OF A LARGE NUMBER OF
THIS UNIVERSITY'S SCHOLARS
ACROSS OUR CAMPUSES AND AT OUR
GLOBAL CENTERS.
WE HAVE BEEN HONORED THAT THE
WHO  DESIGNATED COLUMBIA'S
INTERNATIONAL RESEARCH
INSTITUTE IS A PARTNER IN
PREDICTING DISEASE OUTBREAKS
RESULTING FROM CLIMATE CHANGE.
DR.TEDROS IS ESPECIALLY  WELL-
SUITED TO SHOULDER THIS
RESPONSIBILITY.
DURING HIS TENURE AS ETHIOPIA'S
MINISTER OF HEALTH HE VASTLY
EXPANDED ACCESS TO QUALITY
MEDICAL CARE BITE INSTITUTING
-- BY INSTITUTING FUNDAMENTAL
REFORMS IN THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM.
HE SERVED AS ETHIOPIA'S
MINISTER OF FOREIGN AFFAIRS.
I KNOW WE ARE ALL LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING ABOUT HIS
PLANS FOR THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
SECOND, TODAY MARKS THE LAUNCH
OF THE NEW COLUMBIA PROGRAM ON
GLOBAL HEALTH SECURITY AND
DIPLOMACY.
THIS IS A CROSS DISCIPLINARY
EFFORT INVOLVING THE MEDICAL
CENTER, THE SCHOOL OF
INTERNATIONAL AND PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AND THE EARTH
INSTITUTE'S INTERNATIONAL
RESEARCH INSTITUTE FOR CLIMATE
. IT WILL BE LED BY DOCTOR
MADELEINE THOMPSON AND DOCTOR
WILMOT JAMES.
WILMOT JAMES  WAS A MEMBER OF
SOUTH AFRICA'S PARLIAMENT AND
PROVIDED LEADERSHIP TO THAT
NATION ON A RANGE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH MATTERS IN A MINISTERIAL
CAPACITY.
HE IS A VISITING PROFESSOR AT
THE COLUMBIA MEDICAL CENTER AND
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS.
THIRD, THIS EVENT DIVIDES US
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
STOCK OF HOW THE UNIVERSITY IS
HELPING TO ADDRESS PROBLEMS OF
GLOBAL DIMENSION, ESPECIALLY AT
THIS CONSEQUENTIAL MOMENT IN
WORLD HISTORY.
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR COLUMBIA TO
BE PONDERING ITS RESPONSIBILITY
IN THIS REGARD.
AND WE HAVE BEEN.
GLOBAL SOCIETIES CHALLENGES ARE
MORE SHARPLY DELINEATED THAN
EVER BEFORE.
ALL I HAVE TO DO IS SAY THAT
WITH EMPHASIS AND EVERYONE
KNOWS WHAT I MEAN.
IT HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY
CLEAR THAT 20th CENTURY
INSTITUTIONS AND NORMS ARE NOT
SUFFICIENT FOR ADDRESSING THE
COMPLEXITY AND SCALE OF THESE
PROBLEMS.
WITH THIS IN MIND, WE HAVE
LAUNCHED A FAR-REACHING NEW
INITIATIVE CALLED CLUMPY AT
WORLD PROJECTS.
-- COLUMBIA WORLD PROJECTS.
IT WILL HAVE A PROFOUND EFFECT
IN THE COMING YEARS.
ITS CENTRAL PURPOSE IS TO
HARNESS THE UNIVERSITY'S
CAPACITIES AND KNOWLEDGE IN THE
SERVICE OF PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS,
ALWAYS WITH AN OPENNESS AND AN
EMPHASIS ON WORKING ACROSS AND
BEYOND DISCIPLINES AND WITH
PARTNERS BEYOND ACADEMIA.
FOLLOWING THE REMARKS OF
DR.TEDROS  WE WILL HEAR FROM A
PANEL THAT INCLUDES ELIZABETH
CAMERON WHO IS BECOME THE
SENIOR DIRECTOR AT THE NUCLEAR
THREAT INITIATIVE AFTER SERVING
ON PRESIDENT OBAMA'S SECURITY
COUNCIL.
GAVIN SCHMIDT THE DIRECTOR OF
NASA GODDARD INSTITUTE FOR
SPACE STUDIES AT THE EARTH
INSTITUTE'S INTERNATIONAL
RESEARCH INSTITUTE FOR CLIMATE
AND ARE WELL KNOWN JEFFREY D.
SACHS , ALL OF US KNOW AND
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP HE
HAS PROVIDED TO THIS UNIVERSITY
AND TO THE UNITED NATIONS AND
BEYOND ON SUSTAINABLE ELEMENT
AND FAR MORE.
WE THANK ALL OF YOU AND OUR
SPEAKER DR.TEDROS FOR THE
CONTRIBUTIONS  THAT YOU ARE
MAKING TO IMPROVE MOBILE HEALTH
AND WELL-BEING.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION'S NEW
DIRECTOR GENERAL DR.TEDROS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
KIND INTRODUCTION.
DEAR PRESIDENT BOLLINGER
PROFESSOR SACHS, THIS THING
WITH COLLEAGUES AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, BEFORE I BEGIN MY
ADDRESS, LET ME FIRST EXPRESS
MY DEEP PERSONAL CONCERN FOR
THE PEOPLE OF THE CARIBBEAN
ISLANDS.
THEY SUFFER THIS RELENTLESS
WAVE OF HURRICANES.
THIS IS A FURTHER REMINDER OF
THE MERCILESS SEQUENCES OF OUR
CHANGING CLIMATE.
SHATTERED HOMES, SHATTERED
LIVES.
WHO STANDS READY TO DO  ALL WE
CAN DO TO ASSIST.
BUT NOW LET ME TAKE YOU ON A
JOURNEY.
IT STARTS WITH A SINGLE CASE.
IN A MILITARY CAMP IN KANSAS.
A COOK REPORTS TO THE MEDICAL
CENTER COMPLAINING OF FEVER.
A SORE THROAT.
AND ACHES AND PAINS.
WITHIN MINUTES A SECOND SOLDIER
IS ADMITTED WITH SIMILAR
SYMPTOMS BY LUNCHTIME THE COUNT
HAS REACHED MORE THAN 100.
AND MORE THAN 500 BY THE END OF
THE WEEK.
THE FOLLOWING WEEK THE VIRUS
REACHES NEW YORK.
MANHATTAN.
BATTALIONS ARE SENT TO FIGHT A
WAR IN FOREIGN LANDS.
THE CONFINED LIVING QUARTERS
AND MASSIVE MOVEMENTS OF TROOPS
PROVIDE THE IDEAL CONDITIONS
FOR THE VIRUS TO SPREAD.
WITHIN MONTHS THE EPITOME
SWEEPS ACROSS FIVE CONTINENTS.
IT'S SYMPTOMS INCLUDE NAUSEA,
DIARRHEA, AND DARK SPOTS ON THE
CHEEKS.
THE VIRUS TAKES HOLD, PATIENTS
TURN BLUE.
THEY SUFFOCATE AS THEIR LUNGS
FILL WITH BLOOD.
THERE ARE NO VACCINES TO STOP
THE VIRUS.
AND NO DRUGS TO TREAT IT.
MANY OF ITS VICTIMS ARE YOUNG.
CUTDOWN IN THEIR MOST
PRODUCTIVE YEARS.
SCHOOLS, PLACES OF WORSHIP,
THEATERS, AND OTHER PUBLIC
PLACES ARE CLOSE.
HERE IN NEW YORK BUSINESSES ARE
CLOSING, TIMES ARE STAGGERED IN
ORDER TO AVOID CONGESTION ON
PUBLIC TRANSPORT.
FUNERALS ARE LIMITED TO --
LIMITED TO 15 MINUTES.
THERE IS A SHORTAGE OF COFFINS.
AND THEN, AS SUDDENLY AND AS
INEXPLICABLY AS IT STARTED, THE
PANDEMIC ENDS.
ONE THIRD OF THE WORLD'S
POPULATION HAS BEEN INFECTED.
INCLUDING 25% OF THE U.S.
POPULATION.
50 MILLION PEOPLE ARE DEAD.
THIS IS NOT SOME FUTURE
APOCALYPTIC SCENARIO.
THIS HAPPENED, AS YOU MAY KNOW,
100 YEARS AGO.
THE SO-CALLED SPANISH FLU.
WHICH MAY IN FACT HAVE STARTED
HERE IN THE U.S. IT KILLED MORE
PEOPLE THAN THE FIRST OR
ITSELF.
AND YET IT WAS OVERSHADOWED BY
THE WAR.
AND FADED QUICKLY FROM PUBLIC
AWARENESS.
ITS LESSONS ARE JUST AS
RELEVANT TODAY AS THEY WERE
THEN.
THAT A DEVASTATING EPIDEMIC CAN
START IN ANY COUNTRY AT ANY
TIME.
AND KILL MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT PREPARED.
BUT, WE DO NOT HAVE TO STRETCH
BACK THAT FAR TO BE REMINDED OF
THE CONSEQUENCES OF EPIDEMICS,
THIS CENTURY WE HAVE WITNESSED
OUT BREAKS OF CYRUS, H1N1,
VERSE AND 87 AND NINE.
EACH OF THESE HAS RESULTED IN
SICKNESS, FEAR, AND ECONOMIC
LOSS.
OF COURSE THE MOST DRAMATIC
EPIDEMIC OF OUR TIME WAS THE
EBOLA OUTBREAK OF 2014 AND
2015.
ALTHOUGH IT AFFECTED THREE
WESTERN AFRICA COUNTRIES, IT
EXPOSED FAULTLINES IN GLOBAL
HEALTH SECURITY.
THAT PUT US ALL AT RISK.
ITS SEVERITY WAS CAUSED IN
LARGE PART BY THE WEAKNESS OF
THE HEALTH SYSTEM.
WHICH WAS ILL-EQUIPPED TO
DETECT EBOLA.
AND WAS STRETCHED BEYOND THE
LIMITED CASSA PAT -- CAPACITY
TO RESPOND.
IT WAS NOT JUST THE VIRUS
ITSELF THE KILLED, IN LIBERIA
THE EPIDEMIC CONTRIBUTE TO A
DECLINE IN OUTPATIENT VISITS.
SIERRA LEONE EXPERIENCED A 39%
DROP IN CHILDREN BEING TREATED
FOR MALARIA.
AND 21% DROP IN CHILDREN
RECEIVING BASIC IMMUNIZATIONS.
YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO
THESE KIDS.
IN GUINEA PRIMARY MEDICAL
CONSULTATIONS AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS DROPPED BY
MORE THAN HALF.
AND VACCINATIONS BY ONE THIRD
COMPARED TO 2013.
IN SHORT, THE WHOLE HEALTH
SYSTEMS -- SYSTEM COLLAPSED.
THE SHOCKWAVES OF EPIDEMICS ARE
FELT WELL BEYOND THE DEVASTATED
FAMILIES.
AND LONG AFTER THE LAST
SURVIVORS LEAVE TREATMENT
CENTERS.
IN 2003 SARS CLOSED UP TO --
COST UP TO $59 BILLION
ACCORDING TO THE ASIAN
DEVELOPMENT BANK.
IN 2009 THE H1N1 ENDEMIC WHITE
2.8 BILLION OF MEXICO'S TOURISM
INDUSTRY AND LED TO A TRADE
DEFICIT OF US$27 BILLION.
AS A RESULT OF THE EBOLA
OUTBREAK, THE INTERNATIONAL
MONETARY FUND REDUCED ITS
GROWTH PROJECTIONS FOR ALL OF
SUB-SAHARAN AFRICA BY 10%.
EBOLA ALSO CAUSED COMMODITY
PRICES TO PLUMMET AND LED TO
HIGHER UNEMPLOYMENT AND
PHYSICAL DEFICITS.
EBOLA TOLD US A VALUABLE --
TAUGHT US A VALUABLE LESSON.
GLOBAL HEALTH SECURITY IS ONLY
AS STRONG AS ITS WEAKEST LINK.
I REPEAT, MOBILE HEALTH
SECURITY IS ONLY AS STRONG AS
ITS WEAKEST LINK.
LET'S PUT IT ANOTHER WAY.
NO ONE IS SAFE UNTIL WE ARE ALL
SAFE.
THIS MEANS ALL COUNTRIES NEED
TO HAVE RESILIENT AND ROBUST
SYSTEMS TO PREVENT, DETECT AND
RESPOND TO PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES AT A NATIONAL
LEVEL.
WE MUST SUPPORT GOVERNMENTS TO
BUILD THAT CAPACITY.
EVERY MONTH W.H.O.
SCREENS  AROUND 5000 SIGNALS OF
NEW OUTBREAKS ACROSS THE WORLD.
WE MONITOR THESE CAREFULLY
BECAUSE IGNORING ANYONE OF THEM
CAN BE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
GLOBAL SPREAD OF THE DEADLY
DISEASE AND RAPID INTERRUPTION
OF TRANSMISSION.
EVERY DAY, SOMEWHERE IN THE
WORLD W.H.O.
IS OUT IN THE FIELD WITH  LOCAL
OFFICIALS INVESTIGATING THE
POTENTIAL OUTBREAK.
WHEN AN ALERT SOUNDED EARLY
ENOUGH, AS WHEN IT EBOLA ROQUE
IN THE DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC OF
THE CONGO EARLIER THIS YEAR, WE
CAN MOVE QUICKLY TO SUPPORT
GOVERNMENTS AND STOP THE
OUTBREAK AT ITS STORES.
-- SOURCE.
THAT OUTBREAK IN NEED TO MAKE
-- WAS CONTAINED IN A FEW
WEEKS.
ALSO, TOO FREQUENTLY THE
TRAGEDY OF WAR CREATES THE
PERFECT CONDITIONS FOR DISEASE
TO SPREAD.
WHEN INFRASTRUCTURE IS DAMAGED
OR DESTROYED, WHEN HEALTH
WORKERS ARE TARGETED AND
KILLED.
WHEN ESSENTIAL MEDICINE CANNOT
GET THROUGH TO THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT THE MOST.
THE WORLD DEFENSES AGAINST
EPIDEMICS START TO CRUMBLE.
IT WAS NO COINCIDENCE THAT
SPANISH FLU, THE GREATEST
EPIDEMIC ERUPTED IN THE MIDDLE
OF WHAT WAS THEN THE GREATEST
WAR THE WORLD HAD KNOWN.
IT WAS NO COINCIDENCE THAT
EBOLA SPREAD IN COUNTRIES THAT
HAVE SUFFERED FROM YEARS OF
WAR.
IT IS NO ACCIDENT THAT CHOLERA
IS SICKENING THOUSANDS IN YEMEN
AS WE SPEAK.
OF COURSE EPIDEMICS ARE NOT THE
ONLY THREAT TO GLOBAL HEALTH
SECURITY.
NATURAL DISASTERS, CHEMICAL AND
BIOLOGICAL ATTACKS, FOOD
INSECURITY AND THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE, WILL HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO PUT PEOPLE'S
HEALTH AT RISK.
THAT IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR
ANTIMICROBIAL RESISTANCE.
THE WORLD ABILITY TO RESPOND TO
INFECTIOUS DISEASE HAS BEEN
UNDERMINED BY THE FAILURE TO
ENSURE THAT MEDICINES REMAIN
EFFECTIVE.
MANY HAVE BECOME RESISTANT TO
THE DRUGS WE HAVE.
AND FEW REPLACEMENTS ARE IN THE
PIPELINE.
IN FACT, TODAY WE ARE LAUNCHING
A NEW REPORT ABOUT THE STATE OF
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
AGAINST SOME OF THE BACTERIA
THAT POSE THE BIGGEST THREAT TO
HUMAN HEALTH.
IT SHOWS THE CUPBOARD IS
DISTURBINGLY BEAR.
WE HAVE NOTHING.
URGENT INVESTMENTS IN RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT ARE NEEDED.
BUT WE ALSO NEED NEW THINKING
ABOUT WAYS TO INCENTIVIZE OUR
PARTNERS IN THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS.
BUT RESEARCH AND DEVELOP AND --
ACTION IS NEEDED ACROSS ALL
SECTORS.
FOR EXAMPLE WE ARE WORKING
CLOSELY TO UNDERSTAND HOW VERSE
IS CROSSING FROM ANIMALS INTO
HUMANS.
WE COLLABORATE WITH
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR TO DETECT,
AND MONITOR AND RESPOND
INFLUENCES DENCH INFLUENCE
VIRUSES WITH PANDEMIC
POTENTIAL.
AT THE SAME TIME AS WE PREPARE
FOR OUTBREAKS AND OTHER
EMERGENCIES WE MUST ADDRESS ONE
OF THE MOST PERVASIVE CAUSES OF
INSECURITY.
THE LACK OF ACCESS OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE TO ESSENTIAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
THERE ARE TWO SIDES OF THE SAME
COIN.
UNIVERSAL HEALTH COVERAGE IS
BASED ON THE MODERN CONVICTION
THAT HEALTH IS HUMAN RIGHT,
THEY REFUSE TO ACCEPT A WORLD
IN WHICH PEOPLE GET SICK AND
DIE, SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY ARE
POOR.
IT MEANS SIMPLY PUT, EVERYONE
CAN GET THE HEALTH SERVICES
THEY NEED, WHEN AND WHERE THEY
NEED THEM.
WITHOUT FACING FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP.
IT SOUNDS OBVIOUS, IF ONLY IT
WAS.
BUT THE REALITY THAT MORE THAN
400 MILLION PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD LACK ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL
HEALTH SERVICES, THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE WHO ARGUE THAT THE
ESTIMATE IS MORE THAN 400
MILLION, AND AT LEAST 100
MILLION PEOPLE ARE PUSHED INTO
POVERTY EVERY SINGLE YEAR
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF PAYING
FOR CARE OUT OF THEIR OWN
POCKETS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT UNIVERSAL HEALTH COVERAGE
IS MORE THAN UNIVERSAL HEALTH
CARE.
YES IT INCLUDES CARE, BUT IT
INCLUDES -- IT ALSO MEANS
PEOPLE CAN GET CARE WITHOUT
RISKING FINANCIAL RUIN.
AFTER ALL, WHAT GOOD ARE HEALTH
SERVICES IF PEOPLE DON'T USE
THEM BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
THEM?
BUT UNIVERSAL HEALTH COVERAGE
GOES WITH INDIVIDUAL HEALTH
SERVICES, PREVENTING DISEASES
AT THE POPULATION LEVEL.
MANY OF THESE DO NOT NEED
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE HEALTH
WORKERS TO BE EFFECTIVE.
SUCH AS TOBACCO TAXATION.
AND PROMOTING HEALTHY EATING.
A HEALTH SYSTEM THAT IS
DELIVERING UNIVERSAL HEALTH
COVERAGE ALSO INCLUDES PERIODIC
SERVICES SUCH AS IMMUNIZATION
AND SCREENINGS.
A STRONG NETWORK OF PRIMARY
CARE CLINICS, OF EVERYDAY
HEALTH NEEDS, AND THE ABILITY
TO PROVIDE MORE COMPLEX CARE IN
HOSPITALS.
WHEN WE DESCRIBE HEALTH SYSTEMS
IN THESE TERMS, OUR MINDS MAY
IMMEDIATELY JUMP TO THE WEALTHY
ECONOMIES OF WESTERN EUROPE.
BUT WE SHOULD ALSO THINK OF
COUNTRIES SUCH AS CHINA,
RWANDA, THAILAND, AND TURKEY.
ALL OF WHICH HAVE MADE STRIDES
IN IMPROVING ACCESS AND
SERVICES AND IN MAKING THOSE
SERVICES AFFORDABLE FOR THEIR
PEOPLE.
TAKE CHINA.
IN THE PAST 20 YEARS CHINA HAS
EIGHT LARGE INVESTMENTS IN ITS
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
MAKING HEALTH SERVICES MORE
EQUALLY ACCESSIBLE TO THE VAST
POPULATION.
THE RESULT HAS BEEN LARGE
DECLINES IN CHILD AND MATERNAL
MORTALITY.
IMPROVED OUTCOMES AND LIFE
EXPECTANCY.
IN RWANDA, HEALTH SYSTEM
REFORMS OVER THE PAST 15 YEARS
INCLUDING THE PROVISION OF
PREVENTIVE SERVICES FREE OF
CHARGE TO THE ENTIRE
POPULATION.
IT IS ALSO MEANT MORE MOTHERS
SURVIVE CHILDBIRTH AND MORE
CHILDREN TO CELEBRATE THEIR
FIRST BIRTHDAY.
RWANDA'S TREATY-BASED INSURANCE
COVERS MORE THAN 80% OF THE
POPULATION.
IN A COUNTRY WHERE 90% OF
PEOPLE WORK IN THE INFORMAL
SECTOR.
HERE IS THE POINT.
FAR FROM BEING A LUXURY, THAT
ONLY RICH COUNTRIES CAN AFFORD,
EVIDENCE AND EXPERIENCE BOTH
SHOW THAT UNIVERSAL HEALTH
COVERAGE IS WITHIN REACH FOR
ALL COUNTRIES.
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS.
EVERY NATION CAN DO MORE WITH
THE RESOURCES IT HAS.
A RECENT W.H.O.
STUDY SHOWS 85% OF THE COSTS
OF ACHIEVING HEALTH TARGETS CAN
BE MET FROM DOMESTIC RESOURCES.
THOSE INVESTMENTS WOULD PREVENT
87 MILLION PREMATURE DEATHS
GLOBALLY BY 2030.
AND ADD AS MUCH AS A POINT FOR
YEARS TO LIFE EXPECTANCY IN
SOME COUNTRIES.
-- 8.4 YEARS TO LIFE EXPECTANCY
IN SOME COUNTRIES.
SOME COUNTRIES WILL CONTINUE TO
NEED AID BUT FOR THE MAJORITY
UNIVERSAL HEALTH COVERAGE IS
AFFORDABLE  AND ACHIEVABLE.
MORE THAN THAT, UNIVERSAL
HEALTH COVERAGE  IS POLITICALLY
SMART.
BECAUSE JUST AS EPIDEMICS CAN
CRIPPLE AN ECONOMY, UNIVERSAL
HEALTH COVERAGE CAN HELP IT
GROW.
THE STRONG RESILIENT SYSTEMS
ARE INTEGRAL TO STRONG
RESILIENT ECONOMIES.
THE LOGIC IS CLEAR.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE HEALTHY, ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES AND NATIONS THRIVE.
WHEN CHILDREN SURVIVE TO
ADULTHOOD THEY BECOME
PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY.
WHEN WOMEN SURVIVE CHILDBIRTH
THEY CAN RETURN TO WORKING OR
CARING FOR THE FAMILIES.
WHEN COMMUNITIES ARE FREE FROM
POLLUTION, HARMFUL PRODUCTS AND
OTHER CAUSES OF DISEASE, THEY
PROSPER.
IT'S SIMPLE.
EVERYONE KNOWS THIS.
TOO OFTEN GOVERNMENTS SEE THE
HEALTH SECTOR AS A COST TO BE
CONTAINED.
THIS IS WRONG.
HEALTH IS AN INVESTMENT TO BE
NURTURED.
BUT THE INVESTMENT IN HEALTH IS
VERY COMPELLING.
THE WORLD TOP ECONOMISTS
ESTIMATE THAT EVERY SINGLE
DOLLAR SPENT ON HEALTH YIELDS
UP TO US$20 IN FULL INCOME
GROWTH WITHIN A GENERATION.
THE HEALTH SECTOR IS A GROWING
SOURCE OF JOBS.
AMONG OECD COUNTRIES EMPLOYMENT
IN THE HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SECTORS GREW BY 48% BETWEEN
2000 IN THE HEALTH AND SOCIAL
2020 14.
WHILE JOBS IN INDUSTRY AND
AGRICULTURE DECLINED.
AND BECAUSE -- JOBS FOR HEALTH
WORKERS ARE ALSO JOBS FOR
WOMEN.
ALL OF THIS MEANS THAT FOR MOST
COUNTRIES, THE ONLY REAL
BARRIER IS POLITICAL WILL.
THE ONLY REAL BARRIER IS
POLITICAL WILL.
WITHOUT EXCEPTION, EVERY
COUNTRY WITH UNIVERSAL HEALTH
COVERAGE OR SOMETHING CLOSE TO
IT  HAS GOTTEN THERE BECAUSE AT
SOME POINT IN ITS HISTORY ITS
LEADERS ACTED WITH FORESIGHT,
COURAGE AND MORAL CONVICTION.
THAT IS MAKING A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN COUNTRIES.
NOT RESOURCES.
THERE IS NO SINGLE PASS.
EVERY COUNTRY MUST FIND ITS OWN
WAY.
IN THE CONTRACT -- CONTEXT OF
ITS OWN CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT THE STARTING POINT IS A
DETERMINATION TO CREATE A
HEALTH SYSTEM THAT ON ONE HAND
PROTECTS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES FROM INCAPACITATING
ILLNESS AND FINANCIAL
CATASTROPHIC AND ON THE OTHER,
GUARDS AGAINST HEALTH THREATS
THAT CAN CRIPPLE AN ENTIRE
ECONOMY.
SO WHAT CAN WE DO?
IN MY FIRST WEEK AS DIRECTOR
GENERAL, I WAS HONORED TO BE
INVITED TO ADDRESS THE G 20 IN
HAMBURG ON THIS VERY TOPIC OF
HEALTH SECURITY.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT I TOLD
THEM.
FIRST, WE NEED TO SUPPORT
COUNTRIES TO MAKE PROGRESS
TOWARD UNIVERSAL HEALTH
COVERAGE.
BY STRENGTHENING HEALTH
SYSTEMS, ESPECIALLY IN THE MOST
FRAGILE PARTS OF THE WORLD.
AND THOSE IN THE GRIP OF
CONFLICT.
THIS IS WHAT W.H.O.
DOES ALL AROUND THE WORLD EVERY
DAY.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS GLAMOROUS WORK
BUT IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
SECOND, WE MUST PRIORITIZE
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
MEDICAL COUNTERMEASURES THROUGH
THE W.H.O.
BLUEPRINT.
IT IDENTIFIES THE PATHOGENS
THAT ARE THE MOST LIKELY TO
SPARK AN EPIDEMIC.
DEVELOPING NEW VACCINES AND
DRUGS IS NOT THE WHOLE
SOLUTION.
BUT IT IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF
IT.
THIRD, IT IS VITAL THAT WE MAP
GLOBAL CAPACITIES FOR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE.
UNLESS WE KNOW WHICH COUNTRIES
HAVE ITS CAPACITIES, IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO DEPLOY THEM
QUICKLY.
WHEN A FIRE STARTS, IT'S THE
WRONG TIME TO ASK, WHERE IS THE
EXTENT SURE?
-- FIRE EXTINCTION?
AND FORTH, REGULAR EXERCISE IS
NEEDED TO STRESS TEST OUR
PLANS.
-- AND CHECK LOGISTICS.
THIS IS LIKE A MILITARY DRILL.
OR A SIMULATION EXERCISE.
AGAIN, AN EPIDEMIC IS THE WRONG
TIME TO DISCOVER OUR
PREPARATIONS HAVE BEEN
INSUFFICIENT OR THAT WE HAVE
OVERLOOKED CRUCIAL COMPONENTS
OF THE RESPONSE.
FINALLY AND FIFTH, WE NEED TO
SUSTAINABLY FINANCE THE GLOBAL
HEALTH SECURITY SYSTEM.
TO PREVENT, DETECT AND RESPOND
TO THREATS.
GOVERNMENTS MUST WALK THE TALK
TO ENSURE A GUARANTEED LEVEL OF
CONTINGENCY FINANCING FOR
HEALTH EMERGENCIES.
FINANCING WHEN THERE IS PANIC
DOESN'T HELP.
I THINK WE HAVE TO FINANCE IT
DURING NORMAL TIMES AND PREPARE
FOR IT.
DELIVERING ON THESE PRIORITIES
WILL COST MONEY.
BUT ONLY A FRACTION OF WHAT
REMAINING UNPREPARED WOULD
COST.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, WE DO NOT
KNOW WHERE OR WHEN THE NEXT
GLOBAL PANDEMIC WILL OCCUR.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT IT WILL
EXACT A TERRIBLE TOLL.
BOTH ON HUMAN LIFE AND ON THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY.
AND EVEN MAY CAUSE POLITICAL
INSTABILITY.
BUT WE DO NOT HAVE TO STAND
IDLY BY AND WAIT FOR DISASTER
TO STRIKE.
WE CAN BE PREPARED, OUTBREAKS
ARE INEVITABLE.
BUT EPIDEMICS ARE PREVENTABLE.
THIS IS NOT ONLY A JOB FOR
THOSE OF US IN THE HEALTH
SECTOR, EVERYONE HAS A ROLE TO
PLAY.
FROM THOSE WHO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF OUR FOOD TO THOSE WHO
STRIVE FOR HELP IN THE WORLD.
PREVENTING CONFLICT HELPS
PREVENT DISEASE.
AND PEACE AND SECURITY IS
IMPORTANT.
GUARDING AGAINST EPIDEMICS AND
BUILDING RESILIENT SYSTEMS
REQUIRES DETERMINED SOULS AND
BRIGHT MINDS.
TO PREVENT DISEASE AND TO
PREVENT CONFLICT.
THE WORLD IS PROFOUNDLY
CHANGING IN A NEGATIVE WAY.
FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M
ENCOURAGED THAT A UNIVERSITY
WITH THE STATURE OF COLUMBIA IS
LAUNCHING A GLOBAL HEALTH
SECURITY AND DIPLOMACY PROGRAM.
MAYBE A GIFT FOR ME TO EQUIP
LEADERS WITH THE KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILL TO SOLVE THE CONFLICTS
AND CHALLENGES WE FACE.
I WISH YOU EVERY SUCCESS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU CLOSELY.
I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
-- I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
.
>>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
DR.TEDROS  FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
AT THE W.H.O..
AND HIS VISION FOR ADVANCING
THE GOALS OF GLOBAL HEALTH.
MY NAME IS WILMOT JAMES  AND I
AM A SOUTH AFRICAN MEMBER OF
PARLIAMENT HERE AT COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY AS A VISITING
PROFESSOR IN NONCLINICAL
PEDIATRICS FOR INTERNATIONAL
AFFAIRS.
IT IS A NOVEL JOINT APPOINTMENT
IN TIES TOGETHER THE FIELD OF
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS WITH THE
BUSINESS OF MEDICINE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH.
BEFORE I INVITE OUR ESTEEMED
RESPONDENTS TO REACT TO THE
ADDRESS, IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO THE WORKING
GROUP ON HEALTH SECURITY AND
DIPLOMACY.
IN THE PROGRAM THAT GOES BY THE
SAME NAME.
I'M HONORED TO LEAD IT TOGETHER
WITH MY COLLEAGUE DOCTOR
THOMPSON.
SINCE JULY I HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH COLLEAGUES IN MEDICINE,
PUBLIC HEALTH, CLIMATE SCIENCE,
-- SCIENCE, AND INTERNATIONAL
AFFAIRS IN PUTTING TOGETHER AN
INTERDISCIPLINARY AND
INTERSEXUAL -- -- DESCRIBING
THE BROCHURE WILL FIND IN YOUR
SEAT.
THE PURPOSE OF THE PROGRAM, AS
THIS IS A UNIVERSITY, IS TO
EDUCATE AND TRAIN A NEW
GENERATION OF HEALTH SECURITY
AND DIPLOMACY RESEARCHERS.
PROFESSIONALS AND LEADERS.
IN A CONTEXT DESCRIBED WELL BY
DR. BOLLINGER AND DR.TEDROS  BY
IMMERSING THEM IN THE BEST
AVAILABLE MEDICAL, PUBLIC
HEALTH, CLIMATE SCIENCE, AND
DIPLOMATIC KNOWLEDGE THERE IS.
AND WITH A SPECIAL FOCUS ON THE
NEEDS AND INTERESTS OF
CHILDREN.
IT IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
COLUMBIA TO HAVE SUCH A PROGRAM
AT A TIME WHEN THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION IN THE U.S.
SENDS A RATHER SONG -- STRONG
SIGNAL THAT IT SEEKS TO PULL
BACK FROM ITS GLOBAL LEADERSHIP
ROLE.
IN HEALTH.
THE FACT IS THAT THE WORLD
TODAY FACES BOTH OLD AND NEW
RISKS TO HEALTH.
THERE ARE A GLOBAL SCOPE TO ALL
OF WHICH -- CONTRIBUTE TO
MANAGING.
NO SINGLE INSTITUTION OR
GOVERNMENT CAN DO SO ON ITS
OWN.
IT IS AND MUST BE A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY DRIVEN BY A
SINGLE COMMON PURPOSE OF
ADVANCING HUMAN HEALTH.
WORLDWIDE.
A FOCUS ON THE MEDICINE, THE
PUBLIC HEALTH, DIPLOMACY AND
HEALTH RISK MANAGEMENT IS
PORTRAYED IN THE SLIDE.
IT IS WITH THIS INTRODUCTION
THAT I INVITE DOCTOR JEFFREY D.
SACHS TO RESPOND . HE REQUIRES
NO INTRODUCTION.
BUT I WILL NEVERTHELESS POINT
OUT THAT HE IS A PROFESSOR OF
ECONOMICS, THE LEADER OF
DEVELOPMENT AND HE IS AN AUTHOR
AND COLUMNIST.
HE IS THE FOUNDER OF THE EARTH
INSTITUTE, THE AUTHOR OF THE
MILLENNIUM DEVELOPMENT GOALS
AND AN ADVISOR AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL TO THE UNITED NATIONS AND
GOVERNMENTS WORLDWIDE.
I'VE ASKED HIM AS I HAVE THE
OTHER RESPONDENTS, AS I HAVE TO
MODERATE THE PANEL, TO ALLOW
FOR DISCUSSION AND QUESTIONS
WHICH YOU MAY NOT KNOW IS BY
TRADITION ONLY TO BE ASKED BY
STUDENTS AT THE END.
WOULD YOU PLEASE WELCOME DOCTOR
JEFF TRAN19.
[APPLAUSE]-- DOCTOR JEFFREY D.
SACHS.
ADOT -- [APPLAUSE]
.
>> WELCOME.
WE ARE IN GOOD HANDS..YOU
AGREE?
WE ARE IN WONDERFUL HANDS WITH
DR.TEDROS AT THE HEAD  OF
W.H.O..
IT'S A CRUCIAL INSTITUTION.
AT A VERY COMPLICATED TIME.
I AM PROFOUNDLY GRATIFIED THAT
YOU HAVE HIGHLIGHTED EVERY ONE
OF THE MAJOR CHALLENGES. WE
STILL HAVE BASIC CHALLENGES OF
THE MOST BASIC HEALTH IN POOR
COUNTRIES.
STILL 6 MILLION KIDS ARE DYING
EVERY YEAR UNDER THE AGE OF
FIVE.
OVERWHELMINGLY IN VERY POOR
PLACES, OVERWHELMINGLY OF
READILY PREVENTABLE AND
TREATABLE DISEASES.
THAT IS ONE KIND OF CRISIS THAT
IS SIGNIFICANT.
WE HAVE AS YOU SAID, THE
EMERGING AND REEMERGING
DISEASES WE HAVE BEEN BATTERED
NOW THROUGHOUT HUMAN HISTORY,
BUT ESPECIALLY IN RECENT
DECADES BY ONE NEW DISEASE
AFTER ANOTHER.
REMEMBER THAT AIDS IT SELF IS
IT SO GNOSIS OF A CENTURY AGO
THAT BECAUSE OF THE MEAGER
SURVEILLANCE WAS CIRCULATING IN
AFRICA INFECTING MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE FOR AN
ESTIMATED 60 YEARS AND WAS NOT
DETERMINED UNTIL IT WAS
IDENTIFIED IN SAN FRANCISCO IN
1981.
THAT IS A PRETTY PATHETIC AND
VERY TRAGIC FACT.
BECAUSE THE EVENT THAT PROBABLY
TRIGGERED THE EMERGENCE OF AIDS
TOOK PLACE SOMEWHERE IN WEST
AFRICA PROBABLY AROUND 1920.
THIS IS HOW BAD SURVEILLANCE
IS.
THE RISKS ARE OBVIOUS.
THE IRONY OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
IT IS SUCH AN INCREDIBLY GOOD
FIELD.
IT IS SO CAPABLE.
SO SMART.
YOU GET AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT
FOR VERY LITTLE.
IT'S NOT A LOT OF MONEY TO SAVE
MILLIONS OF LIVES PER YEAR.
AND YET RAISING THAT LITTLE
AMOUNT OF MONEY IS SOMETIMES
UNBELIEVABLY DIFFICULT.
HOW BIG THE FIGHTS WERE TO GET
AIDS TREATMENT STARTED.
SOME KIND OF ORGANIZED MALARIA
RESPONSE.
A BIG THE FIGHTS ARE RIGHT NOW
TO HELP POOR COUNTRIES TO
DEPLOY COMMITTEE HEALTH
WORKERS.
I HAVE BEEN ON THIS NOTE
TOGETHER WITH MY WIFE WHO AS
YOU KNOW LEADS A CAMPAIGN FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS,
WORLDWIDE, AND EVEN IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE WORLD -- IRBIL
AND IT -- BOLA -- IRBIL
EPIDEMIC IT WAS NOT CLEAR TO
GET RESPONSE.
IT WAS PATHETIC.
THE WORLD BANK WHICH I AM ON A
EMAIL EXCHANGE WITH TODAY
CANNOT PUT ONE FOOT IN FRONT OF
THE NEXT TO ACTUALLY GET
FINANCING OUT.
GLOBAL FUND, WHICH I HELPED
START 17 YEARS AGO, AND WHICH
DR.TEDROS CHAIRED  FOR A
BRILLIANT PERIOD, SOMETIMES
CAN'T MOVE.
EVEN WHEN IT'S ABSOLUTELY
URGENT TO MOVE THEN THERE ARE
THE COMPLEXITIES AND CHALLENGES
THAT ARE QUITE DIFFERENT FROM
THOSE OF POVERTY.
THOUGH THEY ARE SPREADING TO
POOR COUNTRIES.
AS YOU SAID, THE FOOD INDUSTRY
IS KILLING US.
THIS IS QUITE HARD BECAUSE THE
FOOD INDUSTRY IS POWERFUL.
IT HAS VAST LOBBYING.
AND IT IS AN INDUSTRY THAT
PRODUCES OBESE GENERIC PRODUCTS
-- OBESE PRODUCTS AND HAS MADE
ADULT AMERICANS ADDICTED TO
UNHEALTHY THINGS.
OF COURSE, THE MORE YOU TRAVEL
THE WORLD THE MORE YOU COME
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES AND
SAY, THAT IS NOT FOOD.
WHAT WE SEE HERE IS NOT FOOD.
IT IS ORGANIC PROBABLY, MOSTLY
BUT IT IS NOT FOOD AND IT IS
HORRIBLE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE GREAT HEALTH
THREATS WE FACE.
BUT IT IS VERY POLITICAL.
JUST AS TOBACCO IS VERY
POLITICAL.
EVEN WHEN YOU KNOW IT, YOU CAN
IDENTIFY, YOU KNOW THAT SUGAR
BEVERAGES ARE HORRIBLE.
FOR HEALTH AND FOR MENTAL WELL-
BEING AND FOR MANY OTHER
THINGS.
WE CAN'T MOVE BECAUSE MODERN
CAPITALISM, I ALWAYS SAY I WANT
TO BE IN A BUSINESS NEXT TIME
THAT HAS AN ADDICTIVE PRODUCT.
YOU GET LOTS OF CUSTOMERS ALL
THE TIME.
THIS IS HOW OUR SYSTEM WORKS.
BUILD ADDICTIONS, MAKE A LARGE
PROFITS, HIGHER LOTS OF
LOBBYISTS, AND SUSTAIN THE
ADDICTION AS LONG AS POSSIBLE,
WHETHER IT'S TO BACA --
TOBACCO, SODA OIL AND GAS AND
COAL.
IT'S BASICALLY THE SAME MODEL.
WE ALSO HAVE A BIG PROBLEM OF
RESEARCHING -- RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT.
THE U.S. IS INCREDIBLY
PRODUCTIVE RIGHT NOW.
WORLD SCIENCE IS INCREDIBLY
PRODUCTIVE IN NEW RESEARCH.
BUT WE'RE GOING BACKWARDS ON
BRINGING THE RESEARCH TO
ACCESS.
AS WE HAVE PRIVATIZED RESEARCH
RECENTLY, AND BIG PRIVATE MONEY
GOES INTO RESEARCH WHICH IS A
TRIBUTE TO OUR CAPITAL MARKETS,
WE ARE PRODUCING MORE AND MORE
RAKE THROUGH DRUGS THAT ARE
BEING PRICED -- BREAKTHROUGH
DRUGS WHICH ARE BEING PRICED AT
$100,000, NOW THE NEW CANCER
DRUGS ARE AT $500,000 PER
TREATMENT DOSE.
THIS IS REALLY BROKEN.
WE HAVE A CURE FOR HEPATITIS C
WHICH IS A WONDERFUL DRUG.
DEVELOPED BY A SMALL BIOTECH
COMPANY WITH NIH SUPPORT.
IT WAS PURCHASED IN 2011 FOR
$11 MILLION.
THIS CHEMICAL, IT PASSED THE
FINAL PHASE 3 TRIALS AND THEN
GILEAD -- SINCE 2012.
THE PILLS COST ONE DOLLAR TO
MAKE.
THEY CHARGE $1000 PER PILL.
IT IS SEVEN WEEKS, 84 PILLS FOR
A TREATMENT DOSE.
FOR WHAT COSTS $84 TO
MANUFACTURE, THEY ARE CHARGING
$84,000.
OF COURSE, THERE ARE SOME
DISCOUNTS, THEY ALWAYS TELL ME
IT'S ONLY $40,000 IF YOU TAKE
THE DISCOUNTS.
THE STRATEGY IS, WE HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE THERE ARE TWO OR 3
MILLION HEPATITIS C INFECTED
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE DYING SLOWLY OF LIVER
DISEASE.
AND THE GOVERNMENT IS THE ONLY
PROVIDER REALLY, EXCEPT FOR
SOME HIGH-COST PRIVATE
INSURANCE, AND THE GOVERNMENT
SAYS YOU HAVE TO BE PRETTY FAR
GONE BEFORE WE'RE GOING TO
TREAT YOU.
AND SO PEOPLE ARE BASICALLY
TOLD, WHEN YOU ARE NEAR DEATH
COME BACK.
THEN YOU CAN GET THIS DRUG.
IF THIS DRUG OR MASS SUPPLIED
WOULD ACTUALLY AND HEPATITIS C
BECAUSE THIS IS A FULL CURE.
THIS IS NOT LIKE HIV.
THIS IS A FULL CURE.
WE COULD BREAK TRANSMISSION,
WICKED AND THE DISEASE.
THIS IS A HORRIFIC -- WE COULD
BREAK THE DISEASE.
THIS IS A HORRIFIC
MISAPPLICATION OF PATENT
RIGHTS.
HORRIFIC.
I FIND IT FASCINATING WHEN I
WRITE ABOUT IT I GET LOTS OF
HATE MAIL FOR -- HATE MAIL FROM
WALL STREET.
THEY SAY WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
I OFTEN WRITE BACK, PEOPLE ARE
DYING.
AND SERIOUS PEOPLE RIGHT BACK,
SO?
AND I WRITE PEOPLE ARE DYING.
LARGE NUMBERS.
SO, THAT'S HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS
CAN'T GET OVER IT.
AND THAT REALLY IS A MENTAL
DISEASE.
BECAUSE THAT IS NOT A SYSTEM.
NOT A SYSTEM THAT IS PRODUCING
RESULTS.
IF WE PROVIDE LOTS OF WONDERFUL
NEW $500,000 TREATMENTS FOR
CANCER, THAT IS NOT A SYSTEM
THAT IS DOING WHAT IT NEEDS TO
DO.
THIS IS YET ANOTHER CHALLENGE
BECAUSE WE ARE ON AN ABSOLUTE
SCIENTIFIC REVOLUTION RIGHT
NOW.
WE DO NOT HAVE A MODEL OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE TO GO ALONG WITH
THE SCIENTIFIC REVOLUTION.
ALL OF THIS IS TO SAY THAT YOU
HAVE YOUR HANDS FULL.
WE LOVE YOU AND WE WANT TO HELP
YOU.
THANK YOU.[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF I COULD NOW CALL ON BETH
CAMERON WHO IS THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR, GLOBAL BIOLOGICAL
POLICY AND PROGRAMS, NUCLEAR
THREAT INITIATIVE , SHE
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AT THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL IN
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
WHERE SHE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
LAUNCHING THE GLOBAL HEALTH
SECURITY AGENDA AND WORKED IN
THE FOLLOWING AREAS, BIO
SECURITY, BIO DEFENSE, EMERGING
INFECTIOUS DISEASES, RESEARCH
AND BIOTERRORISM.[APPLAUSE]
>> ON THANK YOU.
-- THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME IN
HOSTING THIS EVENT.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY DR.TEDROS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
WHAT I'M GOING TO SPEAK ABOUT
IS  A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF THE GLOBAL HEALTH
SECURITY AGENDA WHICH IS AN
ORGANIZATION OF COUNTRIES,
NONGOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION,
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND NEXT
GENERATION LEADERS THAT EXIST
TO SUPPORT THE W.H.O.
EFFORT TO  IMPLEMENT THE
REGULATIONS.
WHAT YOU SEE IS THAT EVERYTHING
I'M GOING TO SAY STRESSES AND
EMPHASIZES WHAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM YOU AND YOUR GREAT
LEADERSHIP AT W.H.O..
FIRST, IN GLOBAL HEALTH
SECURITY, W.H.O.
LEADERSHIP IS ESSENTIAL.
NOT ONLY W.H.O.
BUT ALSO  THE WORLD
ORGANIZATION FOR ANIMAL HEALTH
AND THE FOOD AND POSITIONAL --
OF THE UN.
IS A GREAT LEADERSHIP THAT
HAPPENS BETWEEN THE
ORGANIZATIONS WHICH IS
INCREDIBLE TO SEE AN ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL TO THE CHALLENGES
THAT DR.TEDROS OUTLINED.
I DON'T HAVE TO CONVINCE THIS
AUDIENCE, AFTER HEARING FROM
DR.TEDROS THE PANDEMICS ARE
CRITICAL.
I THINK THE STORY YOU TOLD  OF
THE 1918 FLU WAS THE MOST
POIGNANT FLEXION OF THIS ISSUE.
BUT I DO THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
AT AN ACADEMIC UNIVERSITY AND
THOSE OF YOU IN THE AUDIENCE
WHO MAY NOT BE IN GOVERNMENT TO
THINK A LITTLE NOT ONLY ABOUT
HEALTH AND HOW HEALTH IMPACTS
SECURITY AND NATIONAL SECURITY.
AS A STAFFER IN THE WHITE HOUSE
DURING THE EBOLA CRISIS, I SAW
FIRSTHAND HAPPENS TO HEADS OF
STATE IN GOVERNMENT FAR FROM
AFFECTED COUNTRIES WHO ARE
HAVING A HARD TIME WRAPPING
THEIR HEAD AROUND WHAT THE
EBOLA OUTBREAK IN WEST AFRICA
MIGHT MEAN FOR THEM.
THERE WAS ABSOLUTELY AND NEED
FOR INTELLECTUAL CAPITAL COMING
OUT OF OUR UNIVERSITIES, COMING
OUT OF OUR CIVIL SOCIETY TO
INFORM THE GOVERNMENT IN THAT
SITUATION.
I'M SO PLEASED TO HEAR ABOUT
THE NEW CENTER BEING LAUNCHED
HERE TODAY.
I THINK HEALTH DIPLOMACY IS
GOING TO BE A VITAL FIELD FOR
THE FUTURE AND I ENCOURAGE SOME
OF THE STUDENTS IN THE AUDIENCE
TO CONSIDER THAT WE NEED YOU.
AND W.H.O.
NEED YOU.
THE GLOBAL HEALTH SECURITY
AGENDA IS A VOLUNTARY
ORGANIZATION OF COUNTRIES
LAUNCHED AFTER THE FIRST CASES
OF EBOLA OCCURRED IN GUINEA.
BUT BEFORE THEY WERE REPORTED
TO W.H.O..
THIS IS PUT TOGETHER IN
RESPONSE  TO THE FACT THAT LESS
THAN 20% OF COUNTRIES ACTUALLY
MADE THE DEADLINE FOR LAMENTING
THE W.H.O.
HEALTH REGULATIONS.
THE GHS A WAS LAUNCHED IN
FEBRUARY IN FEBRUARY 2014 WITH
A NUMBER OF LIKE-MINDED
COUNTRIES WITH A NUMBER OF
BACKGROUNDS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS.
WITH THE IDEA THAT COUNTRIES
AND SECTORS, NOT JUST THE
HEALTH SECTOR BUT MINISTRIES OF
FINANCE, FOREIGN AFFAIRS,
DEFENSE, NEEDED TO COME
TOGETHER TO TALK ABOUT ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT ASSETS OF MOBILE
HEALTH SECURITY FROM NATURAL
THREATS TO BIOTERRORISM.
COUNTRIES WERE ASKED TO MAKE
SPECIFIC COMMITMENTS.
THOSE WERE ASKED TO BE MADE AND
REPORTED BACK ON OVER A PERIOD
OF TIME.
THE GOAL THERE WAS REALLY TO
RAISE ATTENTION TO THE LEVEL OF
HEADS OF STATE HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL AS DR.TEDROS
MENTIONED.
THE G20  AND G7 HAVE FOCUSED ON
THIS FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
CYCLES.
IT IS VITAL TO BE MAINTAINED.
AND HAPPY IT'S HAPPENING HERE
BECAUSE THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO STAY ON THE RADAR
SCREEN OF HEADS OF STATE, --
JUST LIKE OTHER TRANSNATIONAL
THREATS.
ALSO TO INCENTIVIZE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
ACCOUNTABILITY WITHIN
GOVERNMENTS FOR THEIR OWN
HEALTH SYSTEM.
BUT ALSO ACCOUNT ABILITY FOR
THOSE WHO SAY AND MAKE
COMMITMENTS THEY ARE GOING TO
HELP OTHERS.
HOW IS THAT HAPPENING?
HOW IS IT HAPPENING IN COUNTRY
AND OUR DONORS COURT MEETING
AND TRACKING PROGRESS TOGETHER.
-- THIS IS SOMETHING I HAVE
HEARD FROM GLOBAL HEALTH
LEADERS ACROSS THE BOARD.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE.
ULTIMATELY THE BACKGROUND OF
THIS SLIDE IS NOT BECAUSE IT'S
A PRETTY COLOR, IT'S THE COVER
OF A REPORT THAT WAS PUT OUT
EARLIER THIS YEAR CALLED THE
INTERNATIONAL WORKING GROUP ON
PANDEMIC FINANCING.
YOU HEARD THE ABSOLUTE
IMPORTANCE OF FINANCING HEALTH
AND HEALTH THE SECURITY -- AND
HEALTH SECURITY.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT ASKING FOR
MONEY, IT'S ABOUT SUSTAINING
CAPABILITY OVER A LONG-TERM
PERIOD.
TONELLI TO BREAK THE CYCLE
WHERE WE PANIC WHEN WE HAVE AN
OUTBREAK AND SPEND LOTS OF
MONEY AND THEN NEGLECT THE
PERIOD WE DON'T HAVE ONE.
WERE THE INVESTMENTS ARE LESS
COSTLY AND MORE IMPORTANT.
THE GLOBAL HEALTH SECURITY
AGENDA IN CLOSE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE W.H.O.
HAS MADE A NUMBER OF
ACHIEVEMENTS.
THE ONE I QUICKLY I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT , ACTUALLY I WILL
HIGHLIGHT TWO OF THEM, THE
IMPORTANCE OF METRICS.
THROUGH THE GLOBAL HEALTH
SECURITY AGENDA WORKING WITH
W.H.O., A SET OF TARGETS HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL HEALTH
REGULATIONS  WHICH HAVE BEEN
FOLDED INTO THE W.H.O.
DEVALUATIONS FOR HR
IMPLEMENTATION.
THIS PROCESS WAS CRITICAL.
IF YOU WOULD'VE ASKED ME WHEN
WE LAUNCHED GHSA IF WE WOULD'VE
GOTTEN TO THIS POINT,  AND IF
YOU'D ASKED MOST OF OUR
COLLEAGUES AT W.H.O., THEY
WOULD'VE SAID  NO.
HAVING.
ASSESSORS COME INTO COUNTRIES
AND LOOKING AT HEALTH CAPACITY
AND PUBLISHING THE RESULT, IT'S
NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
BUT IT HAS HAPPENED.
W.H.O.
HAS A HUGE TEAM  THAT HAS NOW
DONE ASSESSMENTS IN 50
COUNTRIES WORKING WITH EXPERTS
AROUND THE WORLD.
THAT NEEDS TO CONTINUE.
I KNOW IT IS BEING STRONGLY
SUPPORTED UNDER DR.TEDROS'
LEADERSHIP.
GHSA HAS BECOME A PLATFORM FOR
BRINGING IN  THE PRIVATE
SECTOR, ACADEMIC UNIVERSITY AND
CIVIL SOCIETY.
THAT IS THE PLACE WHERE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE CENTER
BEING LAUNCHED HERE TODAY AT
COLUMBIA CAN PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE.
HOW DO YOU TAKE SPECIFIC GOALS
IN GLOBAL HEALTH SECURITY,
RALLY COMMUNITIES AROUND THEM
IN A MEASURABLE WAY, AND THEN
ACTUALLY MONITOR AND EVALUATE
THE PROGRESS OVER TIME?
THAT IS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS WE
ASKED WHEN GHSA WAS LAUNCHED.
IT'S A PLACE WHERE PROGRESS HAS
BEEN MADE BUT A LOT MORE
PROGRESS, ESPECIALLY FROM THE
NONGOVERNMENTAL SECTOR NEEDS TO
CONTINUE.
I MENTIONED THE JOINT EXTERNAL
EVALUATIONS AND ON THE RIGHT
SIDE OF THE SLIDE IS AN EXAMPLE
OF WHAT ONE OF THE EVALUATIONS
RESULTS LOOKS LIKE.
I HIGHLIGHT THIS EXAMPLE
BECAUSE IT'S WHAT MOST
COUNTRIES LOOK LIKE.
THERE'S A LOT OF YELLOW, A
LITTLE GREEN, AND SOME RED.
THE GOAL HERE IS TO TURN ALL OF
THAT READ AND YELLOW INTO
GREEN.
-- THAT COLOR RED AND YELLOW
INTO GREEN.
THE LAST THING I WILL SAY
QUICKLY, I WILL HIGHLIGHT THREE
CHALLENGES IN GLOBAL HEALTH
SECURITY THAT I THINK THE
GLOBAL HEALTH SECURITY AGENDA
IS FOCUSED ON.
I KNOW ALSO W.H.O.
IS FOCUSED ON AS WELL.
LEVERAGING THE COMMITMENTS THAT
ARE OUT THERE.
THROUGH THE LAST COUPLE OF G7
AND G 38 -- G20 CYCLES  MANY
HIGHLIGHTS HAVE BEEN MADE.
THIS IS ONE EXAMPLE, THE G7 HAS
MADE A COMMITMENT TO ASSIST 76
COUNTRIES TO IMPLEMENT THE
INTERNATIONAL HEALTH
REGULATIONS.
THAT IS A FANTASTIC A MINUTE.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO TRACK DOWN
WHO HAS DONE WHAT OFFER HOW
LONG AND TO MEASURE THE
RESULTS.
I THINK THAT IS ANOTHER PLACE
WHERE CIVIL SOCIETY CAN HELP
THE MEASURING RESULTS, BY
LOOKING AT WHAT'S BEEN DONE.
AND FOR HELPING KEEP COUNTRIES
ON TRACK FOR THE COMMITMENT
THEY MADE.
SECOND, I MENTIONED
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE
ULTIMATE GOAL IS, THERE WILL BE
AN EXTERNAL EVALUATION IN EVERY
COUNTRY.
EVERY COUNTRY WILL HAVE A
NATIONAL PLAN.
BY EVERY COUNTRY I DON'T JUST
MEAN COUNTRIES THAT HAVE HAD
MORE CHALLENGES TO THEIR HEALTH
SYSTEM, I MEAN EVERY COUNTRY.
THE UNITED STATES WENT THROUGH
A JOINT EXTERNAL EVALUATION
WHEN I WAS AT THE WHITE HOUSE
AND WE FOUND PROBLEMS THAT
NEEDED TO BE FIXED.
HAVING A NATIONAL PLAN,
FINANCING A NATIONAL PLAN,
HAVING THE POLITICAL COMMITMENT
TO KEEP THE FINANCING GOING AND
THEN ULTIMATELY CONTINUING
EFFORT BY HELPING OTHERS TO GET
PREPARED.
THE NONGOVERNMENTAL GLOBAL
HEALTH SECURITY CONSORTIUM PUT
OUT A CALL FOR THE UPCOMING
MINISTERIAL FOR GHSA  WHICH
WILL BE HELD NEXT MONTH.
WE ASKED THAT BY 2019 COULD 75
COUNTRIES REALISTICALLY HAVE A
NATIONAL PLAN BASED ON THE WORK
W.H.O.
IS DOING?
COULD THOSE NATIONAL PLANS BE
FINANCED?
COULD THERE BE A FINANCIAL
STRATEGY IN PLACE?
THIS IS A HUGE HOLE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT IT
MIGHT NOT BE ACHIEVABLE.
BUT I ASK THOSE OF YOU IN THE
AUDIENCE AND DR.TEDROS TO
CONSIDER  THIS GOAL, BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY IF IT COUNTRY HAS A
FINANCED NATIONAL PLAN IT'S
MORE LIKELY THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT IT.
AND GET PREPARED.
FINALLY, JUST TO REALLY
EMPHASIZE AND FOOT STOMP A
POINT THAT DR.TEDROS MADE,
WHICH IS LOOKING AT HEALTH
SECURITY IS REALLY IMPORTANT IN
AND OF ITSELF.
BUT IT'S VITAL TO LOOK AT
HEALTH SECURITY AND THE BROADER
CONTEXT OF HEALTH SYSTEMS
ACROSS THE BOARD AND ALSO
UNIVERSAL HEALTH COVERAGE.
THESE ARE ISSUES LEADERS HAVE
FOCUSED ON OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
MORE AND MORE UNDER DR.TEDROS'
LEADERSHIP AND WITH CONTINUING
INTEREST FROM COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD UNIVERSAL HEALTH
COVERAGE IS BECOMING AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
GLOBAL HEALTH SECURITY SHOULD
NOT COMPETE WITH THIS.
IT SHOULD COMPLEMENT THIS.
TEAM PREPARED FOR PANDEMIC
THREATS IS PART OF YOUR OVERALL
HEALTH SYSTEM AND PART OF
ACCESS TO SERVICES.
HE SAW HOW THOSE WERE
INTERTWINED UP CLOSE AND
PERSONALLY DURING THE EBOLA
OUTBREAK.
URGING THOSE OF YOU THAT WORK
IN THIS FIELD TO THINK ABOUT
THESE NOT AS COMPETING
PRIORITIES BUT AS THREE AREAS
THAT ACTUALLY ALL NEED TO GET
ATTENTION AND FOCUS.
I WILL STOP THERE AND SAY I'M
INCREDIBLY PLEASED TO BE THERE
-- INCREDIBLY PLEASED TO BE
HERE AND THANK YOU DR.TEDROS
FOR COMING.[APPLAUSE] .
>> I MUST SAY THAT THE
PANELISTS ARE EXTREMELY
DISCIPLINED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTION.
THE FINAL RESPONDENT IS DOCTOR
GAVIN SCHMIDT  CLIMATE
SCIENTIST AND DIRECTOR,
NASA/GODDARD INSTITUTE FOR
SPACE STUDIES, THE EARTH
INSTITUTE, COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY .
HE WORKS IN UNDERSTANDING THE
DRIVERS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
HE WAS A WINNER OF THE ADU
CLIMATE COMMUNICATION PRIZE IN
2011.
HIS 2010 TED TALK HAS BEEN SEEN
BY MORE THAN 1 MILLION PEOPLE.
THINK YOU FOR COMING.[APPLAUSE]-
- THANK YOU FOR
COMING.[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HONORED PANELISTS, RESPECTED
GUEST'S.
I'M GOING TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
IMPACT THAT THAT HAS ON HUMAN
HEALTH AND WELL-BEING.
NASA IS ONE OF THE LEAD
AGENCIES THAT MONITORS CLIMATE
CHANGE, THAT STUDIES THE
PROCESSES THAT UNDERLIE OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THE
CLIMATE SYSTEM AND WORTH IT --
EARTH SYSTEM WORK.
IT BUILDS THE MODELS USED -- TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THINGS HAVE
CHANGED BEFORE AND WHY THEY ARE
CHANGING NOW.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS OFTEN THOUGHT
OF AS A PURELY PHYSICAL
PHENOMENA.
CHANGES IN THE TEMPERATURE, THE
RAINFALL, THE WINDS.
THE STORMS.
BUT AT ITS HEART, CLIMATE
CHANGE IS A HUMAN PROBLEM.
BECAUSE ALL OF THOSE THINGS DO
NOT OCCUR IN A VACUUM.
THEY DO NOT OCCUR ON A PLANET
WHERE THERE IS NO SOCIETY OR
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE.
ARE CONCERNS -- ARE CONCERNS
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE -- ARE
CONCERNS ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
ARE ASSOCIATED NOT WITH JUST
THE INTELLECTUAL PURSUIT OF
UNDERSTANDING, BUT WITH THE
VERY REAL IMPACT THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE HAS ON PEOPLE,
SOCIETIES, AND ECOSYSTEMS.
WHEN IT COMES TO HUMAN HEALTH,
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
RANGE FROM THE OBVIOUS AND
PERHAPS NOT THAT SERIOUS, TO
THE INDIRECT AND PERHAPS
DEVASTATING.
WE CAN ALL THINK OF WHAT
HAPPENS TO HUMAN HEALTH IN
PLACES WHERE THERE ARE GREATER
NUMBERS OF HEAT WAVES.
PEOPLE WHO SUFFER THROUGH HEAT,
A CLASSIC EXAMPLE IN EUROPE IN
2003.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
DIED PREMATURELY BECAUSE OF THE
HEAT WAVE AND AN INSUFFICIENT
AMOUNT OF OPERATION, AIR-
CONDITIONING, AND LOOKING AFTER
PEOPLE.
WE COULD SEE PEOPLE DROWNED
WHEN THERE ARE FLOODING EVENTS.
WE CAN SEE PEOPLE INJURED BY
STRONG WINDS.
THIS LAST MONTH HAS BEEN A
CATALOG OF DIRECT WEATHER,
PERHAPS CLIMATE IMPACT OF
EVENTS, TAKING A TOLL ON HUMAN
HEALTH.
BUT I THINK THE MORE WORRYING
AND CONCERNING ASPECTS ARE THE
INDIRECT ONES.
WHAT HAPPENS TO INFRASTRUCTURE
WHEN THERE ARE INCREASES IN
INTENSE PRECIPITATION?
WHAT HAPPENS TO INFRASTRUCTURE
WHEN THERE ARE INCREASING
NUMBERS OF THE HEAT WAVES?
WHAT HAPPENS TO SOCIETIES AND
SYSTEMS AND UTILITIES AND POWER
LINES AND SEWAGE SYSTEMS WHEN
THERE ARE LARGE FLOODING
EVENTS?
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF INDIRECT
IMPACTS THAT LEAD DIRECTLY TO
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS IN
MIAMI, IN MIAMI-DADE COUNTY IS
THE FACT THAT WHEN THERE IS
FLOODING, THERE IS AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF SEWAGE THAT IS KEPT
IN SEPTIC TANKS BECAUSE MOST OF
THE HOUSES ARE NOT CONNECTED TO
PROPER SEWAGE LINES.
SO WHEN THE WATERS FLOOD AND
RISE, IT'S NOT WATER, IT'S
SEWAGE.
IN HOUSTON, WHEN THE WATERS
ROSE THEY FLOODED CHEMICAL
PLANTS AGAIN PRODUCING SLICKS
OF NOT WATER BUT TOXIC
POLLUTANTS.
THESE ARE VERY DIRECT HEALTH
IMPACTS ON THE POPULATIONS.
THERE ARE OTHER ASPECTS, THEIR
DISEASE VECTORS, PESTS,
PARASITES, WHOSE LIFECYCLE
DEPENDS ON CERTAIN ASPECTS OF
THE CLIMATE.
THE TEMPERATURE.
WHETHER IT GETS COLD DURING THE
WINTER OR NOT IS A BIG FACTOR
IN THE PINE BEETLE OUTBREAK.
AGAIN, WHICH IS LEADING TO
INCREASED RISK OF FIRE, ANOTHER
HEALTH IMPACT.
THE INDIRECT IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ON SYSTEMS THAT ARE
PERHAPS ALREADY STRESSED BY
MANY OTHER STRESSORS, ARE GOING
TO BE, AND THIS IS A
PREDICTION, ARE GOING TO BE THE
BIGGEST IMPACT.
NOW OUR ABILITY TO ASSESS THE
COSTS AND DAMAGES ASSOCIATED
WITH THESE INDIRECT IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IS AT ITS
INFANCY.
THERE'S GREAT WORK BEING DONE
AT THIS UNIVERSITY AND OTHERS
ON TRYING TO LINK THESE THINGS
TOGETHER AND TO TRY AND GET
ESTIMATES OF THE INDIRECT
COSTS.
IT IS STILL VERY MUCH A WORK IN
PROGRESS.
AND ONE HOPEFULLY THAT THE NEW
INSTITUTE WILL BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS MORE THOROUGHLY.
WE CAN ALSO STEP BACK A LITTLE,
WHAT ARE THE CAUSES OF CLIMATE
CHANGE?
WHAT ARE WE ACTUALLY DOING TO
CREATE CLIMATE CHANGE?
WE ARE BURNING FOSSIL FUELS AND
WEIRD BEFORE STATING-- BEFORE
STING.
-- D4 STATION.
THOSE ACTIONS IN THEMSELVES
HAVE OTHER DIRECT IMPACTS.
WHEN YOU BURN FOSSIL FUELS, YOU
PRODUCE SMOKE IN GREATER
NUMBERS OF BRONCHIAL PROBLEMS
AND ASTHMA ASSOCIATED WHEN YOU
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF CARBON
DIOXIDE IN THE AIR AND THE
ACIDITY OF THE OCEAN AFFECTING
COMMUNITIES AND ECOSYSTEMS, ALL
ACROSS THE SURFACE WHEN WE
CHANGE HOW WE PRACTICE
AGRICULTURE, WE INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF NITRATES IN THE
SYSTEM, THAT GOES INTO THE
WATERWAYS AND IMPACTS ALGAE AND
BLUES AND HUMAN HEALTH.
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD IN
SEEING WHAT OUR CHOICES ARE AS
SOCIETIES TO MITIGATE, TO
ADAPT, WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
PUT ALL OF THESE THINGS
TOGETHER, ASSESS NOT JUST
WITH THE CLIMATE IMPACTS WILL
BE IN THE DIRECT AND INDIRECT
IMPACTS BUT WHAT THE DIRECT
IMPACTS OF THE ACTIONS WE ARE
TAKING WE'LL HAVE.
WE HAVE DONE ANALYSES FOR THE
UN ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAM THAT
DEMONSTRATE VERY CHEAP MEASURES
TO REDUCE BLACK CARBON, METHANE
ADMISSIONS -- EMISSIONS, IT CAN
HAVE ENORMOUS BENEFITS.
NOT JUST FOR CLIMATE AND AIR
POLLUTION, BUT FOR HUMAN HEALTH
AND FOR THE ECONOMY DIRECTLY.
EVEN IF YOU DON'T INCLUDE THE
INDIRECT CLIMATE EVENTS LIKE I
MENTIONED EARLIER.
AGAIN, WE ARE AT THE BEGINNING
OF THINKING IN A JOINED UP ONLY
ABOUT THESE.
CLIMATE IS ONE STRESSOR.
IT IS STRIVING -- IT IS ADDING
TO OTHERS, WAR, ECONOMIC
COLLAPSE, -- IT IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE ONLY DRIVER
WITH A SINGLE CAUSE OF MANY OF
THE PROBLEMS WE'RE GOING TO
SEE.
IT IS GOING TO BE INCREASINGLY
ONE OF THE KEY AND IMPORTANT
ELEMENTS IN THOSE EVENTS.
WHEN WE'RE DOING THAT
PREPARATION, WHEN WE'RE STRESS
TESTING OUR SYSTEMS, WE NEED TO
BE FACTORING IN THE SEA LEVEL
RISE, WE NEED TO BE FACTORING
IN THE FLOODING, WE NEED TO BE
FACTORING IN THE CHANGES IN
DISEASE FACTORS.
AND THE IMPACTS ON EMISSIONS.
THIS IS A HUGE CHALLENGE BOTH
INTELLECTUALLY AND FOR SOCIETY.
JEFF MENTIONED HOW DIFFICULT IT
CAN BE WHEN YOU HAVE SITUATIONS
OR TOPICS THAT ARE HEAVILY
POLITICIZED, CLIMATE CHANGE IS
ONE OF THOSE TOPICS.
BUT THAT SHOULD REDOUBLE OUR
ENTHUSIASM AND OUR PROMISE TO
DO A BETTER JOB ON
INCORPORATING ALL OF THESE
FACTORS INTO THE GLOBAL HEALTH
AGENDA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU TO DR. SCHMIDT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN  I WILL
START THE DISCUSSION AND WE
WILL HAVE THE PANELISTS RESPOND
TO SOME QUESTIONS.
WE WILL LEAVE SOME TIME,
DEPENDING ON HOW MUCH TIME WE
HAVE, BUT WE SHOULD TAKE AT
LEAST THREE QUESTIONS FROM THE
FLOOR.
THEN WE WILL CLOSE AT 6:30
PROMPTLY.
IF I MAY BEGIN BY SAYING THE
FOLLOWING, THE U.S. SPENDS $14
BILLION ON GLOBAL HEALTH,
THAT'S EXCLUDING ON ITSELF.
THE UK SPENDS $4 BILLION.
THE BUDGET OF THE W.H.O.
IS BETWEEN $1.9 MILLION AND $2
MILLION.
MOST OF THE WORLD DEPENDS ON
THE W.H.O.
FOR HEALTH.
AND RESPONSES TO EMERGENCIES.
WITH THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
THE W.H.O.
HAS , IT IS I'M SURE, SEVERELY
STRETCHED IN MANY WAYS.
THE QUESTION THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO POSE FIRST TO DR.TEDROS  IS,
IN WHICH WAYS WILL HE INCREASE
THE REVENUE FLOW FROM MEMBER
STATES IN TERMS OF FEES AND
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS FOR
PROGRAMS, AND HOW IN THIS NEW
WORLD OF PUBLIC-PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS, WHAT SMART WAYS
THAT HE HAS IN MIND IN FORGING
COLLABORATIONS WITH A RANGE OF
PLAYERS IN THE GLOBAL HEALTH
AREA.
I WOULD LIKE TO DRAW ON DOCTOR
SACHS AS WELL.
WHAT IS HIS VIEW, WHAT ARE HIS
APPROACHES AND NEW IDEAS IN
TERMS OF GENERATING MORE
REVENUE FOR THE W.H.O.
TO DO ITS WORK .
>> THANK YOU.
I THINK THE FINANCING WILL
DEPEND ON WHETHER MEMBER STATES
BELIEVE IT'S RELEVANT OR NOT.
I THINK FROM MANY OF THE
MEETINGS, AND TODAY IN THE
PRESENTATION, W.H.O.
RELEVANCE CUT NO ONE QUESTIONS
IT.
FOR OUR GLOBAL HEALTH SECURITY
AN ORGANIZATION LIKE W.H.O.
IS IMPORTANT.
SO EVERYONE UNDERLINES . THAT
IS TRUE, FROM THERE YOU HAVE TO
RESOURCE IT.
IF YOU BELIEVE THIS
ORGANIZATION IS YOURS, THEN YOU
HAVE TO COMMIT TO PAY FOR ITS
ACTIVITIES.
AND THERE ARE SOME THINGS WE
ARE PUTTING TOGETHER NOW IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS FINANCIAL
PROBLEMS, NOT ONLY ASKING FOR
MEMBER STATES BUT ALSO SOME
THINGS INTERNALLY.
NUMBER 1, PRIORITIZATION IS
IMPORTANT.
THAT CREATES VALUE.
W.H.O.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO  PRIORITIZE
WHAT IT DOES AND FOCUS ON MAJOR
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
NUMBER 2, IN ADDITION TO THE
TRADITIONAL DONORS, EXPANDING
THE DONOR BASE IS IMPORTANT.
WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN SIGNS THAT
SOME COUNTRIES ARE WILLING TO
CONTRIBUTE.
NUMBER 3, EVEN WITH THE
EXISTING DONORS, THE FUNDING
SHOULD BE FLEXIBLE.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE SOME MONEY
AND YOUR MARKET FOR SOMETHING.
BUT YOU HAVE SHORTAGES FOR
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE A
PRIORITY.
W.H.O.
SHOULD BE TRUSTED BY THE MEMBER
STATES SO BASKET FUNDING OR
FLEXIBLE FUNDING IS IMPORTANT.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT WE NEED
TO MOVE INTO NEW MECHANISMS
ALSO.
INNOVATIVE FINANCING.
YOU SAY PRIVATE SECTOR, PRIVATE
SECTOR IS KEY.
WE HAVE TO INVOLVE PRIVATE
SECTOR AS A SOURCE OF FINANCING
ALSO.
OF COURSE, IT SHOULDN'T BE IN A
WAY THAT AFFECTS THE FUNCTIONS
BECAUSE THOUGH SHOULD ALSO BE
-- THERE SHOULD BE A BALANCE.
SOMETHING WE HAVE SEEN, MAYBE
YOU CAN GIVE ME SOME FEEDBACK,
THE INNOVATIVE FINANCING COULD
INCREASE MORE RESOURCES TO
W.H.O..
ONE AREA IS W.H.O.
IS A KNOWLEDGE-BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE HOW CAN WE
USE -- HAVE MET AND THEY ARE
WILLING.
WILLING TO HELP IN USING THOSE
PLATFORMS BE MOBILE OVER
FACEBOOK AND GOOGLE IN ORDER TO
RAISE FUNDING FOR W.H.O..
YOU MAY NOT BELIEVE IT.
FOR INSTANCE, -- PANIC AND
NEGLECT.
DURING PANIC A LOT OF MONEY
COMES BECAUSE THAT IS DURING
ACTUAL EPIDEMICS.
BUT AS SOON AS THEIR -- THAT IS
GONE THERE IS NEGLECT.
FROM THE CONTINGENCY FUND WE
NEED FOR W.H.O.
$100 MILLION,  THERE IS A
DEFICIT OF MORE THAN 50%.
IT IS REALLY SAD.
THERE SHOULD BE A FLEXIBLE AND
SUSTAINABLE FINANCING AND THAT
WE BELIEVE SHOULD INCLUDE THE
NEW FINANCING AKIN-ISMS, THE
INNOVATIVE ONES, THAT SHOULD BE
SUSTAINABLE AND FLEXIBLE.
WE ARE EXPLORING ALL THE
AVENUES.
INCLUDING THE MEMBER STATES
WHICH WE EXPECT TO INCREASE
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS.
THAN THE LAST PART ON FINANCING
IS THERE IS A FINANCE DIALOGUE
WITH MEMBER STATES TO RAISE
MONEY THAT MODEL DOESN'T WORK.
IT PUTS W.H.O.
ON ONE SIDE AND MEMBERS ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
W.H.O.
BEGGING AND THE MEMBER STATES
AS DONORS.
BUT THE OBJECTIVES OF W.H.O.
ARE THE MEMBER STATES
OBJECTIVES.
THERE IS NO US AND THEM.
THERE'S ONLY US.
MEMBER STATES SHOULD TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY IN RAISING
FUNDS.
SO THE MODEL SHOULD CHANGE.
THAT IS ONE THING WE ARE
UNDERLINING.
AND MEMBER STATES ARE
CONSIDERING THIS SERIOUSLY.
THE SECOND IS WHEN WE DISCUSS
RAISING FUNDS FOR W.H.O.,
INSTEAD OF STARTING FROM
FINANCING W.H.O.
WE SHOULD START FROM DISCUSSING
ABOUT FINANCING GLOBAL AGENDA.
WITHIN THAT WHAT IS NEEDED FOR
W.H.O.
. INTO OUR RESOURCE
MOBILIZATION WE'RE BRINGING
THESE TWO MAJOR SHIFTS.
ONE, IT'S NOT US AND THEM.
MEMBER STATES HAVE THE
OBLIGATION TO RAISE THE
FUNDING.
AND 2 WE RAISE THE FUNDING AND
WE HAVE TO RAISE ENOUGH FUNDING
FOR THE BIG EMBLEM WHICH IS
RESOURCES, GLOBAL AGENDA AND
WITHIN THAT RESOURCING W.H.O.
BASED ON ITS NEEDS.
SO BASED ON THESE SHIFTS WE
HAVE STARTED DIALOGUE WITH
MEMBER STATES AND WE'RE SEEING
GOOD SIGNS AND WE WILL PUSH IN
THAT DIRECTION.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO LISTEN TO
WHAT JEFF SAYS AND HE IS
ALREADY HELPING ME.
HE KNOWS THIS BETTER.
IT IS HIS TERRITORY.
HE PROMISED TO CONTINUE TO HELP
W.H.O. .
I'M GLAD I HAVE A PARTNER HERE.
THANK YOU.
>> DOCTOR SACHS, IN YOUR
RESPONSE COULD YOU ADDRESS THE
QUESTION OF CHILDREN AND THE
MILLENNIUM DEVELOPMENT GOALS ON
CHILD HEALTH?
AND THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
UNICEF WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
CHILD HEALTH AND THE W.H.O..
AND RESPOND TO THE QUESTION OF
FINANCING.
>> ALMOST EVERYTHING SAID ABOUT
FINANCING IN THE PUBLIC DEBATE
IS CONFUSION.
WE HAD IT WHEN TRUMP YESTERDAY
SAID HOW THE UN IS BLOATED AND
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO SEE CUTS
AND SO FORTH.
THE U.S. CONTRIBUTION TO THE
UN, TO THE BASIC BUDGET IS $600
MILLION PER YEAR.
THAT'S 7.5 HOURS OF PENTAGON
SPENDING.
THERE IS NOTHING BLOATED.
WE'RE STARVING THE
INTERNATIONAL SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT A BLOATED SYSTEM.
WE'RE STARVING IT.
THIS THING WE ARE NOT STARVING
IS A MILITARY MACHINE WHERE THE
SENATE YESTERDAY DISGRACEFULLY
VOTED $700 BILLION BUDGET CUT
EVEN MORE THAN TRUMP ASKED FOR.
AND TO GO BEYOND TRUMP THEY
HAVE TO BE CRAZY AND AFRAID.
THIS IS THE FIRST POINT.
WE DON'T USE OUR WEALTH AT ALL
SANELY AND NOT AS PEOPLE THINK
AND NOT AS WE NEED TO DO.
SO WE UNDER INVEST INCREDIBLY
IN THIS.
A SECOND POINT THAT WAS TAKEN
IS THAT EACH COUNTRY SHOULD
LOOK AFTER ITSELF.
THIS IS PRESSED ALL THE TIME.
THIS IS BOGUS.
WE SHOULD LOOK AFTER EACH
OTHER.
WE NEED TO BREAK THIS HOLD
WHICH COMES FROM THIS COUNTRY,
SHE IS A LOUSY NOVELIST THAT IS
CONFUSED FOR A PHILOSOPHER ONLY
IN AMERICA.
DO YOU WANT A PHILOSOPHER?
GO READ ARISTOTLE.
A RANT -- IT IS POOR FICTION.,
THIS IDEA YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN
REALLY PERMEATES THE GLOBAL
DISCOURSE.
EVEN IN YOUR CHARTS, THERE
WASN'T POVERTY.
EVERY COUNTRY SUPPOSED TO HAVE
THEIR PLAN BUT SOME COUNTRIES
CAN'T HAVE THEIR PLAN.
THEY DON'T HAVE A BUDGET TO DO
THIS BUT IF I GO TO OMB EVEN
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE TO GET THIS
STUFF.
WE HAVE TO BE REALISTIC, ALWAYS
LOOKING AT WHAT ARE NEEDS AND
WHAT THE BUDGETS ARE.
AND WE HAVE TO BREAK THE MYTH
THAT THIS SHOULD BE LEFT TO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
I WENT TO FACEBOOK A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO AND SAID I WANT HELP
ON GLOBAL EDUCATION.
THEY SAID WHERE YOU COMING
HERE?
GO TO WASHINGTON.
WE ARE A BUSINESS.
OKAY, I SAID YOU PAY YOUR TAXES
AND I WILL GO TO WASHINGTON.
AND THEN I WAS THROWN OUT OF
THE BUILDING.
WE HAVE A GAME GOING ON, THESE
COMPANIES DON'T PAY THEIR
TAXES, THEY ARE ALL IN THEIR
TAX HIDEAWAYS, WHICH BY THE WAY
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO VISIT
THEIR WAY -- VISIT THEIR MONEY
SOME OTHER PLACE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BEEN DESTROYED BY THE
HURRICANES WHICH IS WHERE THE
HEDGE FUND INDUSTRY DECIDES --
RESIDES.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE GOING TO
DO TO VISIT THEIR MONEY THIS
WEEK.
AND WE DON'T HAVE THE PUBLIC
REVENUE.
WE HAVE A MESS, BUT THE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD NOT BE THE
ONE TO DO THINGS.
IT'S NOT EFFICIENT.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE GREAT
SCIENTIFIC BREAKTHROUGHS THAT
HAVE COME FOR THE LAST 75
YEARS, THEY HAVE COME IN
GOVERNMENT WORK.
WEATHER IN NASA, OR DARPA, WE
GET A LOT OF INNOVATION OUT OF
THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE WE INVEST PUBLIC
MONEY, FORTUNATELY THEY DO
CIVILIAN WORK, NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF HEALTH, WE SHOULD
BE PUTTING A LOT OF MONEY INTO
W.H.O.
IT TO HELP  THE AGENDA.
BUT THIS IS ALMOST UNIMAGINABLE
RIGHT NOW.
THE TRUTH IS, AND I WILL STOP,
WE ARE SO RICH YOU CANNOT
REALLY BELIEVE IT.
UNTIL YOU WALK IN MIDTOWN ON
THE EAST SIDE AND THEN YOU KNOW
IT.
BECAUSE THINGS ARE BOOMING
HERE.
THERE IS SO MUCH WEALTH YOU
CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE, THE
RESTAURANTS ARE PACKED.
I WONDER HOW MANY HUNDREDS, HOW
DO THEY PAY THESE MEALS?
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
WEALTH.
BUT NO ONE IS PAYING THEIR
TAXES.
AND THE TAXES, IF THEY ARE PAID
ARE GOING TO THE MILITARY.
AND THEN WE ARE HEARING THIS
LIKE WE HEAR FROM THE PRESIDENT
WHO IS A VERY CONFUSED PERSON
ANYWAY, BUT SOMEONE GAVE HIM
SOMETHING TO SAY, THAT SAYS,
THE UN IS BLOATED.
IT TURNS OUT APPARENTLY JUST
HIS GOLF TRIPS GOING TO COST
THE TAXPAYERS MORE THAN $60
MILLION PER YEAR, MAYBE WELL
MORE THAN $60 MILLION.
BY ONE ESTIMATE MORE THAN $100
MILLION PER YEAR.
THAT'S A GOOD PLACE TO START
FOR INNOVATIVE FINANCING.
DONALD TRUMP COULD PAY FOR HIS
OWN GOLF TRIP AND MAYBE THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT COULD PAY FOR
W.H.O..
MY OTHER ADVICE WOULD BE
SERIOUSLY, THE U.S. IS NOW THE
DRAG ON THE WHOLE INTERNATIONAL
SYSTEM.
IT SAYS NO TO ALL FINANCE AND
THEN IT SAYS TO OTHERS, YOU
DON'T PAY EITHER BECAUSE WE ARE
EX-SHARING CAUGHT WE DON'T WANT
TO LOSE OUR VETO.
IT TRIES TO HOLD EVERYBODY TO
MINIMUM.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THE DAY
WHEN CHINA IS GOING TO AMPLY
FUND THESE INSTITUTIONS, INDY
IS GOING TO AMPLY FUND THESE
INSTITUTIONS.
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE GOING TO
AMPLY FUND THESE INSTITUTIONS.
THE UNITED STATES DOESN'T WANT
TO DO IT, EVERYONE WILL KNOW WE
ARE ALL GOING TO SURVIVE.
IT'S NOT SUCH A BIG DEAL
BECAUSE THERE IS THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
AT THE U.S. SHOULD NOT LET WHAT
IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY HOLD
BACK THE REST OF THE WORLD.
THIS CRAZINESS COMING FROM THIS
COUNTRY CANNOT BE THE LIMITING
FACTOR FOR THE FINANCING WE
NEED.
SO THERE.[APPLAUSE]
>> WE CERTAINLY THINK DR. SACHS
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THESE
ISSUES.
IF I CAN TURN TO DOCTOR CAMERON
AND ASK THE FOLLOWING QUESTION.
THE GLOBAL HEALTH SECURITY
AGENDA WAS FINANCED THROUGH AN
EMERGENCY CONGRESSIONAL OF THE
BILLION DOLLARS, IT'S GOING TO
RUN OUT NEXT YEAR.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE
APPETITE IN THE CURRENT
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT?
AND JUST AS A SIDE QUESTION TO
THE ISSUE OF FINANCING IN THE
ROLE OF THE U.S. MILITARY IN
MEDICINE, THE U.S. MILITARY
PLAYS A HUGE ROLE, EVERY
POSITIVE ROLE IN TERMS OF SOME
OF THE DISCOVERY SCIENCE,
VACCINE DEVELOPMENT, THINK OF
WHAT THEY DO AT WALTER REED
INSTITUTE, QUITE EXTRAORDINARY
WORK IN THE AREA OF DISEASE
DETECTION, AND SO ON.
AN ISSUE POLITICALLY IS HOW ONE
LEVERAGES THAT.
I'M ASKING THE QUESTION, WHAT
IS YOUR VIEW OF HOW TO LEVERAGE
THAT SIDE OF THE FUNDING
WITHOUT COMPROMISING SPENDING
ON HEALTH AS A PUBLIC GOOD.
BECAUSE IT'S OFTEN THE
CRITICISM THAT IT'S DOMINATED
BY MILITARY INVOLVEMENT IN
FOCUSES ON THE SECURITY SIDE
THAN THE PUBLIC SITE IN TERMS
OF HEALTH.
>> THOSE ARE BOTH GREAT
QUESTIONS.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM.
I THINK IN TERMS OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT FUNDING CONTRADICT
THE FIRST QUESTION FIRST, U.S.
GOVERNMENT RECEIVES
APPROXIMATELY $1 BILLION FOR
GLOBAL HEALTH SECURITY IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE EVIL OUTBREAK.
THAT WAS EXTRAORDINARY TO BE
HONEST.
IT WAS FORWARD THINKING.
IT WAS LOOKING AT THE FUTURE
WHILE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
CRISIS.
IT WAS HARD TO GET THAT FUNDING
OUT OF A REPUBLICAN CONGRESS.
I WILL TELL YOU.
BUT THEY PROVIDED IT.
THE CRITICAL POINT WITH THAT
FUNDING THOUGH WAS THAT IT WAS
TIED TO SPECIFIC METRICS THAT
NEEDED TO BE ACHIEVED BY THE
FUNDERS IN COOPERATION WITH THE
GOVERNMENT'S.
I DON'T MEAN TO IMPLY THEY WERE
ALL ON THE COUNTRIES, THEY WERE
ALSO ON OUR OWN SPENDING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE UNDERSTOOD
WHAT WE WERE DOING AND THAT
WOULD HELP BUILD SUSTAINABLE
CAPACITY THAT WOULD HELP
IMPLEMENT THE IHR.
THE OFFICE OF MANAGEMENT AND
BUDGET LOOKED AT THE GLOBAL
HEALTH SECURITY AGENDA AND ITS
TARGETS THAT HAVE BEEN BUILT
BEFORE THE FUNDING CAME IN AND
MADE THE DECISION TO ASK FOR
THAT FUNDING BECAUSE THEY KNEW
IT COULD BE MEASURED.
BECAUSE THERE WERE SOME TARGETS
THAT HAD BEEN ACHIEVED AND
BECAUSE W.H.O.
AND OTHERS  ALREADY AT THE
TABLE.
THAT WAS ESSENTIAL.
I THINK IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
FUNDING FOR GLOBAL HEALTH
SECURITY IN THE CURRENT CLIMATE,
AND THEY WILL SAY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS SUPPORTED
THIS ISSUE RHETORICALLY, THEY
SAID THEY SUPPORT GLOBAL HEALTH
SECURITY AND THE AGENDA, I
THINK IN ORDER TO SEE FUNDING
FOR THIS, THERE HAS TO BE AN
EXTRAORDINARY EFFORT TO
ADVOCATE FOR IT AND FOR
CONGRESS TO PROVIDE IT.
AND TO BE ABLE TO SHOW THAT IT
IS A COMMON GOOD THAT IS
ESSENTIAL FOR GLOBAL PEACE AND
SECURITY AND U.S. NATIONAL
SECURITY.
I THINK THOSE ARGUMENTS CAN BE
MADE.
BUT I THINK THE FUNDING NEEDS
TO COME IN FOR CDC AND USAID
AND THE BUDGETS THAT ARE OUT
THERE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE AND STATE TO BE AT THE
TABLE AND GLOBAL HEALTH AND
SECURITY NEED TO BE MAINTAINED
BECAUSE THE MULTISECTORAL
BUDGET HELPS BRING A LITTLE
SECTORS TO THE TABLE AND OTHER
COUNTRIES.
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL WHEN YOU
ARE HAVING FINANCING
CONVERSATIONS AND WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO LOOK AT MEASURABLE
GOALS.
I'LL TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
QUICKLY RESPOND TO WHAT DOCTOR
SACHS SAID.
I COMPLETELY AGREE THAT NOT ALL
COUNTRIES CAN DO THIS ON THEIR
OWN.
AND ABSOLUTELY SHOULDN'T.
BUT I DO THINK EVERY COUNTRY
THAT HAS A GOVERNMENT,
RECOGNIZING THERE ARE COUNTRIES
AND POPULATIONS IN THE WORLD
THAT DON'T HAVE THAT LUXURY AT
THE MOMENT, CAN LOOK AT THE
PLANNING PUT IN PLACE.
AND W.H.O.
HAS WORKED IN PLACES ALL OVER
THE WORLD INCLUDING  COUNTRIES
THAT ABSOLUTELY CAN'T FIND ITS
THIS FOR THEMSELVES TO PUT
TOGETHER A HEALTH SECURITY
PLAN.
THE HEALTH SECURITY PLAN IS
TAILORED TO THEIR PRIORITIES
AND NEEDS.
THAT IS VITAL AND I THINK
THAT'S HELPFUL IN BRINGING
SECTORS OF GOVERNMENT PLACES
THAT OTHERWISE WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE.
BUT PROVIDING HEALTH AND
SUPPORT.
AT THE PLACE WHERE W.H.O.
AND ITS LOCAL LEADERSHIP  IS
ESSENTIAL.
WE LOOK AT SUPPORTING W.H.O.
JUST CRITICAL, WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING NOT ONLY AT SUPPORT IN
GENEVA, BUT TO IMPLY THAT YOU
SAID THAT, BUT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT SUPPORTING THE
W.H.O.
LOCAL OFFICES.
AND THE EXPERTS ON THE GROUND
WORKING THERE AND ALSO
SUPPORTING HOW THEY PLUG IN TO
THE BROADER DONOR EFFORT.
THEY CAN'T DO IT ALONE EITHER.
THEY NEED THE DONOR GOVERNMENTS
TO HELP.
WE NEED THEM THERE AS WELL TO
BE THE GLUE.
QUICKLY TO RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTION ON MILITARY AND
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE, ONE OF
THE ROLES I PLAY AT THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT WAS IN OVERSEEING
U.S. FUNDING THROUGH DOD FOR
BIOLOGICAL THREAT REDUCTION
WHICH FOCUSES ON BIO
SURVEILLANCE, BIO SECURITY, I
WORKED CLOSELY WITH DEFENSE
HEALTH PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
LABORATORIES ALL OVER THE
WORLD, SOME OF WHICH HAVE BEEN
STANDING IN PLACES LIKE CAIRO,
THAILAND IN KENYA FOR MORE THAN
50 YEARS.
THE WAY THAT THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
MOST SUCCESSFUL IS WHEN THEY
ARE INTEGRATED INTO THE FABRIC
OF THE SOCIETIES IN WHICH THEY
WORK.
IN CAIRO, WHEN I WOULD VISIT
EGYPT, THE WHO -- THE W.H.O.
OFFICE  FOR OUR OVERSEAS
LABORATORY AND OUR OWN U.S.
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS WORKED HAND
IN GLOVE.
IN SOME SITUATIONS I WAS IN, IT
WOULD SAY, I'M WORRIED ABOUT
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
INVOLVEMENT.
BUT I WELCOME 3. YOU WANT TO BE
IN A SITUATION WHERE THOSE
EXPERTS ARE PART OF THE FABRIC
WORKING WITH THE W.H.O.
AND THE HOST GOVERNMENT.
IT'S IMPORTANTLY CONTINUE OUR
INVESTMENT IN THOSE AREAS BUT
THAT WE DO IT NOT AT THE
EXPENSE OF CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL OR THE USAID OR THE WHO.
-- W.H.O..
RIGHT NOW MOST OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT SPENDING FOR GLOBAL
HEALTH SECURITY INCLUDING IN
PLACES LIKE LIBERIA,  WHERE THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE IS
HELPING OF A CENTRAL REFERENCE
LAB WITH THE GOVERNMENT, THAT
IS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT'S THE WAY
IT SHOULD BE BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT.
IT'S HELPFUL IN BUILDING SAFE
AND SECURE FACILITIES AND ITS
HELPFUL BECAUSE IT IS AT LEAST
A FUNDING AND WE NEEDED.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WOULD LIKE TO TURN TO DR.
SCHMIDT AND THE QUESTION OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND SOME OF THE PRACTICAL
THINGS BEYOND WHAT IT IS HE
DESCRIBED.
BUT BY FOCUSING ON WHAT HAS
BEEN OFTEN DESCRIBED AS MARKET
FAILURE IN THE DELIVERY OF
VACCINES AND MEDICAL
COUNTERMEASURES WHEN IT'S
NEEDED.
IT'S PARTICULARLY TRUE DURING
EMERGENCIES AND CATASTROPHES.
I'D LIKE US TO REMEMBER THAT
IT'S NOT JUST PANDEMIC
INFECTIOUS DISEASES BUT ALSO
ACCIDENTAL CHEMICAL SPILLAGES
OR BIOLOGICAL SPILLOVERS,
RADIOLOGICAL AND SO ON.
THERE ARE A RANGE OF THINGS.
THEY ALL REQUIRE A DEGREE OF
HOSPITAL READINESS IN ORDER TO
COPE.
AND THEY REQUIRE VERY
IMPORTANTLY, THE DELIVERY OF
VACCINES WHICH PREVENT
INFECTIONS.
AND MEDICAL THERAPIES TO DEAL
WITH DISEASE.
TO START WITH YOU DR. SCHMIDT,
CAN YOU TELL US  WHAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO KNOW ABOUT CLIMATE
IN ORDER FOR PEOPLE WHO DELIVER
VACCINES FOR EXAMPLE, GLOBALLY,
IT'S A LOGISTICAL QUESTION,
WHAT SHOULD THEY KNOW ABOUT
CLIMATE VARIABILITY THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO PLAN EFFECTIVELY,
ESPECIALLY WHEN DEALING WITH
EMERGENCIES?
>> THAT'S A LITTLE OUTSIDE OF
MIGHT WHEELHOUSE.
LET ME SEE IF I COULD SAY
SOMETHING INTELLIGENT.
SO, ONE OF THE PROBLEM THAT
EXISTS IN DELIVERY OF VACCINES
TO THE MORE FAR-FLUNG AND
DISCONNECTED PARTS OF THE WORLD
IS THAT WE DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE
GOOD WEATHER FORECASTS FOR
THESE PLACES.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH ON THE
GROUND MEASUREMENTS OF
TEMPERATURE, RAINFALL AND THE
WINDS THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO
FEED INTO THE GLOBAL MODELS THE
PRODUCE THE FORECAST THAT CAN
BE USEFUL.
OUR ABILITY TO FORECAST THE
WEATHER IN PLACES LIKE CENTRAL
AFRICA IS MUCH POOR IN OUR
ABILITY TO FORECAST THE WEATHER
IN THE U.S. FOR YOUR.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT CAN BE
FIXED WITH INCREASING
INVESTMENT IN AUTOMATED WEATHER
STATIONS.
THERE WAS A PROJECT THE
COLUMBIA WORKED WITH TO PUT
AUTOMATIC WEATHER STATIONS ON
CELL PHONE TOWERS.
SO AS THE CELL PHONE TOWERS
REACHED FURTHER IN, MORE
INFORMATION WOULD COME BACK AS
WELL.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE MORE
LONG-TERM PROJECTIONS THAT WE
ARE WORKING ON AT THE 20, 30,
40 YOUR LEVEL ARE A PARTICULAR
HELP -- YEAR LEVEL ARE OF A
PARTICULAR HELP IN THE JUST
TICKLE ISSUES.
AT THE NOTION THAT YOU NEED TO
BE THINKING ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT TO WHICH YOU ARE
GOING AND BE ABLE TO TRACK WHAT
IS HAPPENING THERE, WHEN IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN, EVEN IN THE
SHORT TERM, IS OBVIOUSLY
SOMETHING WE WORK QUITE A LOT
ON.
HOW DID I DO?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S A GENERAL PROBLEM.
THERE IS MARKET FAILURE IN
TERMS OF GETTING VACCINES TO
THE RIGHT PLACE AT THE RIGHT
TIME.
THE BIGGER QUESTION WAS RAISED
BY DR.TEDROS IN TERMS OF
HAVING A PIPELINE OF MEDICAL
THERAPIES AVAILABLE THAT IS
PROACTIVE.
THE W.H.O.
LIST OF MOST LIKELY OUTBREAKS
THAT WILL OCCUR IN THE AREA OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
YOU CAN GO TO THE WEBSITE TO
SEE THAT.
YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR TALK, HOW
DO YOU SEE STIMULATING RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT WHEN IT COMES
TO VACCINE DEVELOPMENT?
IT'S AN ROAD PROCESS.
THERE HAS TO BE A PIPELINE THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO PRODUCE THOSE
VACCINES.
WHAT IS THE PERSPECTIVE ON THE
PART OF THE W.H.O.
TO HELP THAT PROCESS?
>> ON VACCINES AND RESEARCH, I
THINK IT WILL BE IMPORTANT
FIRST OF ALL FOR THOSE WITH --
IMPORTANT GOVERNMENTS --
GOVERNMENTS SHOULD BE WILLING
TO INVEST.
BECAUSE THERE ARE MARKET
FAILURES OR THE PRIVATE SECTOR
WILL NEVER GO TO THAT
TERRITORY.
THAT IS ONE.
THE SECOND, FOR THOSE THAT HAVE
SOME INTEREST IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR, I THINK THE ADVANCED
MARKET, THAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT.
A COMBINATION OF THE TWO.
GOVERNMENTS PLUS THE ADVANCED
MARKET COMMITMENTS FOR THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
THIS WOULD REALLY HELP.
BY THE WAY, ON THE DRUGS FOR
HEPATITIS C, WHEN AREA, WE ARE
DOING THAT, US$120.
THAT WILL HELP AND WE CAN GO TO
ELIMINATION NOW.
>> JUST NOT IN THE U.S. IN
ADDITION TO GENERIC, I THINK
BUILDING THE MANUFACTURING
CAPACITY OF COUNTRIES IS
IMPORTANT A SPECIAL -- AS YOU
KNOW UNDER THE GLOBAL PROGRAM,
MANY MANUFACTURING INDUSTRIES
ARE MIGRATING OUT OF CHINA.
THAT IS A GOOD OPPORTUNITY WITH
AN INCREASING INDUSTRY IN
CHINA.
THAT COULD BE USED TO INCREASE
THE MANUFACTURING CAPACITY OF
THE DEVELOPING WORLD,
INDUSTRIALIZATION, THAT CAN
COME WITH THAT.
AND INDUSTRIALIZATION MEANS
INNOVATION.
I THINK USING THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES WOULD BE
IMPORTANT.
THAT COULD BE APPLIED FOR
VACCINES.
AS WE KNOW, MANY OF THE
EXPENSIVE MEDICINES OR VACCINES
AT THE END OF THE DAY THE ISSUE
IS THE SUPPLY AND DEMAND ISSUE.
SO, IF WE INCREASE SUPPLY, THE
PRICE WOULD BE LOWERED.
THAT IS WHY INCREASING THE
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY OF
DEVELOPING WORLD COULD INCREASE
COMPETITION AND BRING
COMPETITION AND COMPETITION CAN
HELP.
OF COURSE THERE WAS A HIGH-
LEVEL RECOMMENDATION LAST YEAR
AND THERE ARE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE HIGH-
LEVEL, -- BUT THESE ARE
STRATEGIC SOLUTIONS WE NEED TO
TAKE.
ME A COMMENT ON CLIMATE CHANGE?
-- ME I COMMENT ON CLIMATE
CHANGE?
THAT WAS MY PRIORITY WHEN I WAS
CAMPAIGNING FOR THIS POSITION.
ON CLIMATE CHANGE AND HEALTH,
MAYBE I WOULD LIKE TO RAISE TWO
ISSUES.
W.H.O.
IS  MAINLY FOCUSED ON
ADAPTATION.
-- MITIGATION.
THE HEALTH IMPACT OF INCREASED
CARBON RELEASE, AND ITS IMPACT
ON HEALTH.
W.H.O.
SHOULD RAISE THE ALARM.
MORE ADVOCACY AND VERY VOCAL ON
MITIGATION.
MITIGATION IS PREVENTION.
W.H.O.
IS FOR PREVENTION.
WE CANNOT JUST BE AN ADAPTATION
AND ONLY FIX THE PROBLEMS AS
THEY ARISE.
WHICH WE CANNOT FIX ANYWAY.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A SERIOUS
PROBLEM FOR THE WHOLE WORLD.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, IT'S ALSO
A PROBLEM BUT THERE ARE
COUNTRIES THAT ARE MORE
AFFECTED DISPROPORTIONATELY
THAN OTHERS.
WE NEED TO HELP THOSE WITH A
SENSE OF URGENCY.
THESE ARE THE SMALL ISLAND
DEVELOPING STATES.
THEY HAVE TO BE SUPPORTED AND
W.H.O.
IS STARTING A NEW INITIATIVE .
CLIMATE CHANGE AND HEALTH
INITIATIVE AND WE WILL GIVE THE
MORE SUPPORT BECAUSE THEY ARE
IS PROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED.
THAT INITIATIVE WILL HAVE
PROBLEMS AND PROJECTS THAT WILL
COME FROM THE SAME SYSTEMS.
NO ONE SHOULD -- THEY SHOULD BE
THE ONES WHO TELL US HOW WE CAN
HELP THEM.
AND WE CAN FACILITATE AND HELP.
THIS IS ONE OF THE INITIATIVES
WE'RE GOING TO WORK ON.
I KNOW WE WILL HELP IN MAKING
THIS SUCCEED.
BUT WE HAVE TO REALLY HELP
THOSE WHO ARE REALLY
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO STAY FOR A
MINUTE ON VACCINES.
YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED --
CLINICAL TRIALS FOR TWO
VACCINES.
FOR ZIKA VIRUS.
WHAT THEY SAID WAS TWO REASONS,
ONE IS THE EPIDEMIOLOGY OF ZIKA
VIRUS AND THE OTHER IS THE --
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THE WHOLE QUESTION OF THE
PRODUCTION OF VACCINES HAS BEEN
A BOOM AND BUST BUSINESS.
WHEN THERE IS A CRISIS THERE IS
A LOT OF MONEY AND EFFORT, BUT
WHEN IT EBBS THIS DECLINES.
IT IS A RISKY INVESTMENT.
THE QUESTION IS, HOW DO WE GET
IN MORE STABLE FUNDING IN THE
VACCINE BUSINESS?
--
>> I THINK IT'S INTERESTING TO
THINK ABOUT ANOTHER VACCINE
CASE HALF CENTURY AGO, WHICH
WAS THE POLIO EPIDEMIC.
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT CREATED WHAT
BECAME CALLED THE MARCH OF
DIMES.
THE MARCH OF DIMES REFUNDED --
FUNDED THE UNIVERSITY OF
PITTSBURGH RESEARCH COMPANY
CAME UP AT THE VACCINE HE WAS
ASKED FAMOUSLY, WHO OWNS THE
VACCINE?
WHO OWNS THE PATENT?
HE SAYS THE PUBLIC OF COURSE.
COULD YOU PATENT THE SUNSHINE?
THAT IS A WONDERFUL SENTIMENT.
THE VACCINE WAS MADE PUBLIC.
IT WENT TO RAPID APPLICATION.
THE EPIDEMIC WAS ENDED IN THE
HEIGHT INCOME COUNTRIES.
NOW WE'RE ON THE VERGE OF FULL
ERADICATION.
THE POINT IS, IT'S A DIFFERENT
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
DEVELOPMENT MODEL.
A PUBLIC CHANNEL.
BECAUSE OF THE CHALLENGES OF
VACCINES, THE TREMENDOUS PUBLIC
GOOD ASPECTS FOR VERY POOR
PEOPLE, THE MARKET RISKS AND
THE FLUCTUATIONS, THERE SHOULD
BE A MASSIVE PUBLIC EFFORT FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF VACCINES AND
THEIR PROPAGATION.
THERE CAN BE A RESEARCH ARM
ATTACHED TO GAVI AS A MECHANISM
OF THIS.
I WANT TO SAY ANOTHER WORD
ABOUT CLIMATE ISSUE AND AID.
WE TALK ABOUT AID FOR HARD-HIT
COUNTRIES.
BUT IF THIS WERE A COURT OF
LAW, THOSE COUNTRIES WOULD HAVE
CLAIMS.
DAMAGES FOR WHAT IN LAW WOULD
BE CALLED THE PUBLIC NUISANCE,
THAT THEIR RIGHT TO THE RAND
HAS BEEN DAMAGED BY OUTSIDE
INTERFERENCE.
IN THIS CASE BY THE RICH
COUNTRIES.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO PAY.
UNDER THE PARIS CLIMATE
AGREEMENT WE CALL IT LOSSES AND
DAMAGES WHICH IS A CATEGORY.
BUT WHEN THE RICH COUNTRIES
NEGOTIATED THAT, THEY SAID IT'S
NOT COMPENSATION.
BUT OF COURSE IT'S
COMPENSATION.
IT SHOULD BE COMPENSATION.
BECAUSE THE OVERWHELMING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR, CHANGE IS
NOT A SMALL ISLAND DEVELOPING
STATES OR THE HORN OF AFRICA OR
THE CARIBBEAN AND OTHERS, IT IS
THE RICH COUNTRIES.
YOU CAN EVEN FIND -- FIND THE
COMPANIES BECAUSE EXXON AND
CHEVRON ARE AT THE TOP OF THE
LIST OF HISTORICAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
THEY SHOULD BE NABBED RACKLEY
IN COURT FOR THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE -- DIRECTLY
IN COURT FOR THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE LANGUAGE.
THIS COMES BACK TO THE IDEA
THAT SOMEHOW WE THINK WE ARE
IMMUNE TO RESPONSIBILITY BUT WE
HAVE TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE RESPONSIBILITY.
I WANT TO PUT AID, NOT AS AN
IRRELEVANT CATEGORY, I WANT TO
PUT AID IN COMPENSATION AS THE
RELEVANT CATEGORY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I JUST GOT A NOTE TO SAY THAT
DR.TEDROS HAS ANOTHER
ENGAGEMENT AND HE HAS TO BE
THERE NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
SO I WAS HOPING TO GET AT LEAST
TWO QUESTIONS FROM STUDENTS.
AND I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO
COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
>> I WILL INTRODUCE MYSELF
QUICKLY.
HAVE A QUESTION FOR DR. SACHS.
CAN ASK THAT AFTER DR.TEDROS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
I ACTUALLY USED TO BE AT THE
UNITED NATIONS, I WAS A FORMER
ADVISOR TO THE GROUP OF FRIENDS
FOR GENDER PARITY.
WE ARE 100 COUNTRIES ADVOCATING
FOR GENDER EQUAL LEADERSHIP OF
THE UN SECRETARIAT.
IT WAS IN A CONVERSATION WITH
ONE OF YOUR PREDECESSORS, WHICH
IS ONE OF THE REASONS I'M HERE
PURSUING A DEGREE IN MEDICINE,
MY QUESTION IS WITH THIS
GROWING PATTERN OF ISOLATION
WORLDWIDE AND THE LACK OF
FUNDING WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT A
LOT, THERE ARE MAJOR GAPS IN
THE GLOBAL HEALTH AGENDA.
WHERE EXACTLY THE PRIVATE
SECTOR CAN FILL IN THOSE GAPS,
NOT JUST IN TERMS OF RAISING
FUNDS AND FINANCING CERTAIN
ASPECTS, BUT IN TERMS OF THE
ROAD PROCESS  OR MAYBE DONATING
CERTAIN DRUGS THAT ARE IN NEED
IN CERTAIN PLACES WHICH IS
DIFFICULT.
THAT LEADS INTO MY SECOND
QUESTION.
>> PLEASE HOLD IN YOUR SECOND
I'M GOING TO ASK DR.TEDROS TO
RESPOND.
HE DOES HAVE TO LEAVE.
I'M AFRAID THERE WON'T BE ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS TO DR.TEDROS.
>> THIS ISN'T THE QUESTION,
JUST TO FINISH THE QUESTION,
HOW YOU CAN INCENTIVIZE THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO BE INVOLVED
AND TAKE OWNERSHIP IN THIS
GLOBAL HEALTH AGENDA.
>> YOU ARE GIVING ME ONE.
THANK YOU.
IT HAS ACTUALLY TWO QUESTIONS.
I THINK YOU RAISED THE GENDER
PARITY ISSUE AND THEN I DON'T
KNOW WHY YOU FORGOT IT.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE
QUESTION.
I CAN REFRAME IT LIKE A
ARE YOU GOING TO DO GENDER
PARITY IN YOUR TOP LEADERSHIP?
>> MY QUESTION IS CLARIFY,
THERE ARE MAJOR GAPS NOT JUST
FINANCING AND FUNDING IN THE
GLOBAL HEALTH AGENDA, HOW THE
PRIVATE SECTOR CAN FILL IN
THOSE GAPS THAT YOU CAN
IDENTIFY.
AND ALSO HOW YOU CAN
INCENTIVIZE THE PRIVATE SECTOR
TO TAKE OWNERSHIP AND BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION.
>> ONE OF THE OPPORTUNITIES WE
HAVE IS THE FRAMEWORK TO ENGAGE
THE PRIVATE UNITED STATES
ACTORS.
THE PRIVATE SECTOR BEING ONE.
WE HAVE THAT FRAMEWORK THAT WAS
CREATED LAST YEAR.
BASED ON THAT, THAT OPENS UP
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENGAGE THE
UNITED STATES ACTORS.
AND WE WILL TRY TO BENEFIT FROM
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS.
BUT WE HAVE, ONE THING I NEED
TO ADMIT IS, W.H.O.
IS A BIT AFRAID OF ENGAGING THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
I THINK THAT IS WHAT YOU'RE UP
TO.
AND WE SHOULDN'T REALLY BE
WORRIED BY THAT.
THERE SHOULDN'T BE ANY
CONDITION TO ENGAGE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
WE KNOW WHERE THE CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST MAY ARISE.
WE SHOULD BE CONSCIOUS ABOUT
THAT.
BUT THERE SHOULDN'T BE FEAR IN
ENGAGING THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
IT ALL STARTS FROM THERE.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE MINDSET.
AND WE HAVE TO BELIEVE WE CAN
WORK WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
WHILE STILL SAFEGUARDING THE
AREAS THAT SHOULD BE
SAFEGUARDED.
OR REALLY MANAGING THE CONFLICT
OF INTEREST.
TO DO THAT, FOR THE PRIVATE
SECTOR, WE NEED TO HAVE A CLEAR
STRATEGY.
BASED ON THE PRIORITIES WE
HAVE.
TO SEEK THEIR ENGAGEMENT.
FIRST WE SHOULD KNOW OUR
PRIORITIES.
AND THEN SIT DOWN AND DISCUSS
THE PRIORITIES IN THE
ENGAGEMENT SHOULD NOT BE AT THE
GLOBAL LEVEL ONLY, IT SHOULD GO
UP TO COUNTRY LEVEL ON HOW THE
PARTNERSHIPS COULD BENEFIT THE
GLOBAL AGENDA WHICH IS A
PRIORITY FOR ALL OF US
INCLUDING THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
SO THIS IS THE FRAMEWORK WE ARE
TRYING TO FOLLOW.
AND I HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN TO
SOME OF THEM IN THE LAST 79
DAYS SINCE I HAVE STARTED MY
NEW POST, AND THE ENGAGEMENT I
HAD WAS VERY CANDID.
WE HAD A CANDID DISCUSSION, IT
ALL STARTS THERE.
WE NEED TO BE HONEST WITH EACH
OTHER.
SO WE WILL INVOLVE THEM IN MANY
OF THE MAJOR ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE AND WE WILL NEED THEIR
SUPPORT.
IT SHOULDN'T BE AS YOU RIGHTLY
SAY JUST FINANCE.
MANY AREAS WHERE WE CAN
PARTNER.
OUR PARTNERSHIP SHOULD BE BASED
ON TRUST AND ALSO VERY CANDID
DISCUSSIONS AND HONEST
RELATIONSHIPS THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DR.TEDROS.
WE NOW HAVE TO RELEASE
IS A FORMER POLITICIAN I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS MEANS.
WE HAVE TO DO THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK HIM FOR
COMING.[APPLAUSE]
>> AS HE IS WALKING OUT TO SAY
IT IS OF THE GREATEST
IMPORTANCE THAT WE SUPPORT THE
WORK OF W.H.O..
THE ONLY GLOBAL BODY WITH
UNIVERSAL LEGITIMACY.
ANYONE WHO DOES ANY WORK
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD REQUIRES
COVER FROM THE W.H.O..
THEREFORE IT'S QUITE IMPORTANT
FOR US TO SUPPORTED.
AND HIS WORK.
WE STARTED LATE AND WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE AND WILL RUN UNTIL
25 MINUTES UNTIL SEVEN TO GIVE
STUDENTS A CHANCE FOR QUESTIONS.
ASK A QUESTION AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
>> MY NAME IS LUKE NELSON.
I AM A STUDENT HERE.
I AM STUDYING PSYCHOLOGY.
LAST SUMMER I WAS ONE OF A FEW
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS WHO GOT
A CHANCE TO GO TO HAITI AND
STUDY MATERNAL HEALTHCARE AND
ACCESSIBILITY TO MATERNAL
HEALTH CARE.
I HAD A CHANCE TO RETRAIN
COMMUNITY HEALTHCARE WORKERS
AND PROVIDE QUALITY CONTROL AND
THE WORK THEY DO ONE THING I
DID NOTICE WAS A SENSE OF
DISCOURAGEMENT AND A SENSE OF
SADNESS SURROUNDING THE ISSUES
AND TIREDNESS IN TERMS OF THE
WORK THAT THEY ACTUALLY DO.
I GUESS MY QUESTION MORE
SPECIFICALLY IS, WITHIN THE
GLOBAL DISCOURSE, AND WITH
HAITI'S ECONOMIC DEPENDENCE ON
EMERGENCY FUNDING AND THE
LOWERING OF FUNDING THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS BY ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
THE USAID AND OTHER PRIVATE
SECTOR FUNDERS, WHAT GOES INTO
RANKING AND UNDERSTANDING WHICH
COUNTRIES TAKE PRIORITY IN
TERMS OF THE HELP AND THE WORK
THAT IS NEEDED TO BE DONE
WITHIN THAT COUNTRY, BUT ALSO I
GUESS HAS THE TERM GLOBAL
HEALTH SECURITY BEEN ADOPTED TO
ENCOURAGE COUNTRIES WHO CAN
SPEARHEAD THESE INITIATIVES
LACKS OR MORE SO, HOW DO YOU
MOTIVATE THESE 70+ COUNTRIES
GIVEN THE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT THEY FACE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF YOU CAN HOLD THE RESPONSE I
WILL TAKE THE NEXT PERSON AS
WELL.
>> I'M A POSTDOC STUDENT AT
COLUMBIA AND HAVE A QUESTION
FOR DR. SACHS.
AS YOU DESCRIBE THE FOOD SYSTEM
HURTS US AN OVERALL POPULATION
HEALTH.
I WANTED TO KNOW WHAT YOU
THOUGHT WOULD BE EFFECTIVE AND
SPECIFIC WAYS TO RESPOND.
THE FOOD INDUSTRY SYSTEM.
>> IF YOU CAN DEAL WITH THAT
QUESTION, AND ON THE QUESTION
OF HAITI, IF DOCTOR CAMERON CAN
RESPOND TO THAT.
THE GLOBAL SECURITY AGENDA.
GO-AHEAD.
>> I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT HAITI, VERY QUICKLY.
THERE ARE TWO KINDS OF ANSWERS
TO THE QUESTION.
ONE IS A FORMAL TEXTBOOK
ANSWER.
WHICH COUNTRIES ARE IN WHICH
LISTS, WHO NEEDS HELP AND SO
FORTH.
THEN THERE IS THE REAL ANSWER.
WHICH IS GEOPOLITICS.
WE DON'T CARE ABOUT HAITI.
PERIOD.
EXCEPT IF THERE IS SOME KIND OF
REFUGEE MOVEMENT OR IF WE WANT
TO OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT.
AND SO IF YOU ACTUALLY LOOK AT
HOW HAITI GOT INTO THIS
UNBELIEVABLY WEIRD SITUATION
THAT IT HAS BEEN IN, AND OF
COURSE THERE ARE MANY THINGS
GOING ON, IF YOU GO BACK TO THE
EARLY 90s, ARISTIDE WAS
OVERTHROWN, THEN THE USD --
THAN THE U.S. PUT ARISTIDE BACK
IN BUT SAID YOU CAN'T REALLY
STAY, SO CLINTON PUT HIM BACK
IN BUT SAID YOU HAVE TO LEAVE
RIGHT AWAY SO THEN THEY PUT IN
PRO BALL, AND THEN ARISTIDE
CAME BACK AND GEORGE W. BUSH
SAID I WANT TO TAKE OUT THAT
GUY SO THEY TRIED TO BREAK THE
GOVERNMENT FOR FIVE YEARS
BETWEEN 2001 AND 2004.
THEN THEY SENT IN THE CIA AND
THEY OVERTHREW HIM.
AND THEY PUT HIM IN THE AIRPLANE
AND CARRIED HIM FOR 23 HOURS TO
CENTRAL AFRICAN REPUBLIC.
IF YOU CHECK, THE NEW YORK
TIMES DID NOT REPORT THAT.
BECAUSE THEY ARE IN BED WITH
THE CIA.
WE COULDN'T EVEN GET STRAIGHT
STORY OF A GUY DEPOSED IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT IN OUR OWN HEMISPHERE.
THAN THEY PUT IN ANOTHER ONE
AND THEN MASSIVE HURRICANES AND
MASSIVE EARTHQUAKES AND
MISMANAGEMENT, AND BILL CLINTON
IN CHARGE, NOTHING RECOVERED.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
THAT'S CALLED GEOPOLITICS.
WE BROKE THE COUNTRY'S ECONOMY
BY REPEATED BOYCOTTS.
SOLVED NOTHING.
AND THERE IS SOME NATIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY ALONG THE WAY
BUT BASICALLY WE WERE OBSESSED,
ESPECIALLY REPUBLICANS WERE
OBSESSED WITH ARISTIDE FOR 20
YEARS AND HE WAS THE ONLY
POPULAR POLITICIAN IN THE
COUNTRY.
IF YOU HAVE THE ONLY POPULAR
PETITION YOU DON'T REALLY
CREATE A BASE FOR LEGITIMATE
ACTION.
THIS IS THE REAL STORY.
ON FOOD, LOOK, FIRST OF ALL WE
SHOULD STATE -- SAY WHAT'S
REALLY GOING ON.
I WILL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
LAST YEAR THE TOP NUTRITIONISTS
IN THIS COUNTRY BUT A CHAPTER
OF THEIR ADVISORY REPORT THAT
SHOWED THAT A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENTAL FOOD PRODUCTION
SYSTEM WOULD ALSO LEAD TO A
HEALTHIER DIET AND THAT WOULD
BE LESS BEEF.
BECAUSE BEEF IS DESTRUCTIVE
ENVIRONMENTALLY AND THAT FOR
THE HEALTH, THE AMOUNT OF THE
AMERICANS ARE EATING.
THE OBAMA SECRETARY OF
AGRICULTURE EXCISED CHAPTER 8
OF THE USDA AND SAID THAT'S
BEYOND THE RECOMMENDATION
BOUNDARIES.
BECAUSE THE FOOD INDUSTRY
APPARENTLY IS IMPORTANT.
AS LOBBYISTS, AND THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO HAVE A CHAPTER THAT
SPOKE STRAIGHTFORWARDLY ABOUT
THESE RISKS.
WE KNOW THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY,
WE KNOW THE BEEF -- WE WERE
ABLE TO TAKE ON TRANS FATS
BECAUSE THE NUTRITIONISTS LED A
REAL CAMPAIGN ON THAT.
AND THE COMPANIES WERE ABLE TO
FIND SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
BUT BASICALLY, THERE ARE A
HANDFUL OF LARGE COMPANIES HERE
THAT HAVE A TREMENDOUS
CULPABILITY IN THE OBESITY
EPIDEMIC.
THEY NEED TO BE HELD TO ACCOUNT
AND NEED TO COME UP WITH A PLAN
FOR PHASING OUT THERE DANGEROUS
PRODUCTS.
WE ARE THE ONLY COUNTRY, IF YOU
LOOK ON THE CHARTS, WHILE WE
ARE NOT THE ONLY COUNTRY, THEY
ARE SPREADING IT OUT TO POOR
COUNTRIES, THE DON'T HAVE
DEFENSES, BUT WE ARE SO MUCH
ABOVE THE OBESITY RATES OF
OTHER HIGH INCOME COUNTRIES
BECAUSE WE ARE SO MUCH MORE
VULNERABLE TO THIS KIND OF
LOBBYING.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DO YOU WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT
ON HAITI?
>> I WILL BE QUICK AND SAY TWO
THINGS.
HAITI WAS PRIORITIZED AS PART
OF THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
COMMITMENT TO ASSIST AT LEAST
30 COUNTRIES.
AND THROUGH THAT PRIORITIZATION
THEY ARE DEVELOPING A NATIONAL
PLAN WITH A LOT OF ASSISTANCE
AND RIGHTLY SO.
FROM CDC AND USAID.
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
IT'S A STEP FORWARD.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO DO.
THE SECOND COMMENT I WILL MAKE
IS JUST THAT THERE ISN'T -- TO
GET TO THE HEART OF THE
QUESTION, WHICH IS A GREAT
QUESTION, I DON'T THINK THERE
IS CURRENTLY A RELIABLE WAY TO
KNOW HOW COUNTRIES FIT WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
HOW THEY RANK.
IN TERMS OF HEALTH SECURITY.
AND HOW THAT FITS WITH THEIR
OVERALL HEALTH SYSTEM.
ONE OF THE PROJECTS THAT HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON, A PILOT SINCE
I HAVE BEEN IT NTI IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE JOHNS
HOPKINS CENTER FOR HEALTH
SECURITY, IS A GLOBAL HEALTH
SECURITY INDEX AND WHETHER IT'S
POSSIBLE TO CREATE ONE USING
INDICATORS NOT JUST THAT RELATE
TO PANDEMIC PREPAREDNESS BUT
THAT ALSO TRACKBACK TO
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND THE
OVERALL HEALTH SYSTEM.
WE'RE JUST COMPLETING THE PILOT
PHASE OF THIS BUT HOPEFUL THAT
A TOOL LIKE THAT WOULD HELP
LOOK AT ALL COUNTRIES WITH A
VERY TRANSPARENT LENS SO THAT
BETTER DECISIONS COULD BE MADE
ABOUT WHO IS AT RISK AND WHAT
THE REAL RISKS ARE.
WE'RE INCLUDING FACTORS ABOUT
WHETHER A COUNTRY IS PREPARED
AND NOT JUST FACTORS THAT THE
GOVERNMENTS THEM -- THEMSELVES
GOOGLE.
I'M SORRY TO KEEP YOU WAITING.
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU IF YOU CAN
PUT YOUR QUESTIONS, ALL THREE,
BUT THEM CRISPLY AND WE WILL
GET THE PANELISTS TO RESPOND
AND THEN CLOSE.
GO-AHEAD SIR.
>> I AM ALSO AN UNDERGRAD.
I SPENT MOST OF MY LIFE GROWING
UP IN GHANA AND MY QUESTION WAS
ABOUT WHAT I HAVE NOTICED.
I KNOW IN GHANA THEY ARE VERY
LIMITED WITH UNIVERSITIES.
EVEN WITH THE UNIVERSITY'S WE
HAVE, VERY FEW OFFER MEDICAL
PROGRAMS ARE HAVE RESEARCH
CENTERS.
THAT HAS LED TO A LOW DOCTOR-
PATIENT RATIO.
I LOT -- I IMAGINE A LOT OF
UNDERDEVELOPED COUNTRIES
EXPERIENCED THE SAME THING.
MY QUESTION IS WHAT EFFORTS IF
ANY HAVE INTERNATIONAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS OR MEMBER STATES
IN W.H.O.
MADE TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM?
IF THERE ARE NO DOCTORS HOW
REALLY DO IMPLEMENT HEALTH
REFORMS AND WHATNOT?
>> THANK YOU.
>> I MATTHEW.
I'M A FRESHMAN.
I WAS WONDERING -- I AM
MATTHEW.
I AM A FRESHMAN.
HEARING THESE SPEAKERS HAS
REINFORCED FOR ME THE NEED FOR
FUNDING FOR THE W.H.O.
AND INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
FULLY SYMPATHIZE FOR THE NEED
FOR THE FUNDING THAT HAD WE
BRING THESE ISSUES TO THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN OR CITIZEN OF
ANY COUNTRY SO WE CAN GALVANIZE
PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR THESE
PROGRAMS THAT SEEM FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE TO BE VERY FAR OFF
ISSUES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND BACK.
DR. SACHS, I THOUGHT IT WAS
INTERESTING YOU USED YOUR
INTRODUCTION TO TALK ABOUT DRUG
PRICING.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE COST OF
MANUFACTURING A DRUG BUT NOT
THE COST OF DRUG DISCOVERY AND
JUST HOW LONG, SIMPLE
STATISTICS.
IT TAKES 20 YEARS TO BRING AN
IDEA TO AN ACTUAL MARKETED
PRODUCT.
THE COST OF CLINICAL TRIALS IN
THOSE THINGS.
HOW CAN YOU FINANCE THE DRUG
DISCOVERY ASPECT OF THE ROAD
PROCESS  AND ALSO INCENTIVIZE
THE ROAD PROCESS  AND STILL
COME UP WITH DRUGS THAT ARE
REASONABLY PRICED?
I THINK YOU HAVE SOME
INTERESTING THINGS TO SHARE ON
THAT.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR THE TERRIFIC
QUESTIONS.
I'M GOING TO ASK EACH PANELIST
TO RESPOND TO WHAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO RESPOND TO.
AND MAKE ANY CLOSING REMARKS.
STARTING WITH YOU DR. SCHMIDT.
>> I'M JUST GOING TO PASS THE
PEOPLE WHO KNOW THE ANSWERS TO
THE QUESTIONS.
>> NO CLOSING REMARKS?
>> I DON'T NEED TO TALK JUST
FOR THE SAKE OF IT.
THANK YOU.
>> I WILL BE QUICK ALSO ON TWO
POINTS THE DON'T ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
IN THE INTEREST OF PASSING
ALONG INFORMATION THAT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL.
IN THE CASE OF DOCTOR TO
PATIENT RATIO, I DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION ABOUT
WHAT'S BEING DONE TO TACKLE
THAT ISSUE.
ON EPIDEMIOLOGY AND OTHER
TRAINING PROGRAMS I HAVE
FOCUSED ON IN THE GLOBAL HEALTH
SECURITY AGENDA, ONE OF THE
ANSWERS TO YOUR QUESTIONS IS
THERE DOES NEED TO BE A
CONCERTED EFFORT, AND HAVING A
STANDARDIZED APPROACH TO THAT
AN UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
ACTUAL GAPS ARE AND WHERE THEY
ARE IN THE WORLD AND HOW TO
ACTUALLY TACKLE THOSE GAPS
GIVEN -- IN THE CONTEXT OF WHAT
THE LOCAL NEEDS ARE.
THAT IS CRITICAL.
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN HEALTH
SECURITY, DONNA HAS BEEN VERY
ACTIVE AND HAS A NEXT-
GENERATION LEADERSHIP SUPPORT
THEIR -- DONNA HAS BEEN VERY
ACTIVE AND HAS A NEXT
VENERATION LEADERSHIP SUPPORT.
AND ON VACCINE DEVELOPMENT ONE
OF THE ENCOURAGING THINGS THAT
HAS HAPPENED OVER THE COURSE OF
THE YEAR IS THE LAUNCH OF THE
COALITION FOR EPIDEMIC
PREPAREDNESS.
IT WAS LAUNCHED TO GET SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS YOU RAISED.
HAVE YOU SHRINK THE TIME FOR
DRUGS TO GET TO MARKET, FOR
CORE DRUGS WE NEED.
BETTER VACCINES AND
THERAPEUTICS.
IN MY PERSONAL OPINION A LOT
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO GET TO
THE POINT WHERE WE HAVE MEDICAL
COUNTERMEASURES AND DIAGNOSTICS
ON-DEMAND WHICH IS SOMETHING WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR
YEARS BUT WE ARE REALLY FAR
AWAY FROM.
>> ONE QUICK POINT ON THE
QUESTION OF DOCTORS AND
POPULATION.
BECAUSE OF MOBILE CONNECTIVITY,
TELEMEDICINE AND THE ADVENT OF
TRAINED COMMITTEE HEALTH
WORKERS, THERE'S A TERMINUS
AMOUNT OF REDESIGN OF HOW
HEALTH SYSTEMS COULD REACH
EVERYTHING.
WE DON'T NEED DOCTORS THE SAME
WAY AS IN A TRADITIONAL SYSTEM.
WE CAN HAVE PEOPLE DOING
OUTREACH.
YOU CAN HAVE RADIOLOGISTS OUT
WORD IN THE WORLD -- ANYWHERE
IN THE WORLD, SOON THERE WON'T
BE TOO MANY RADIOLOGISTS, YOUR
PHONE WILL DO THE READING OF
THE IMAGES, IT WILL TAKE THE
IMAGE AND DO THE IMAGE.
AND INTERPRET IT THROUGH AN
EXPERT LEARNING MACHINE OR
LEARNING SYSTEM.
THERE IS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
INTERESTING INNOVATION GOING
ON.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO
WORK ON SYSTEMS REDESIGNED IN
AN INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY RICH
ENVIRONMENT.
YOU CAN DO A LOT THAT WAS NOT
EVEN POSSIBLE US TO FEW YEARS
AGO.
ON THE QUESTION OF ROAD, I
SHOULD'VE ADDED THAT  THE LID
IN THIS DRUG -- GILEAD IN THIS
DRUG I MENTIONED, WHEN IT
BOUGHT THE PRODUCT, PROBABLY
THE KEY MOTIVE ROAD  -- KEY
MOTIVE ROAD WAS PERHAPS  $.5
BILLION.
GILEAD IS EARNING $15 BILLION
PER YEAR ON THE DRUG.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
ROAD  AND THE ULTIMATE PRICING
IS NOT VERY DIRECT.
IT'S NOT VERY RATIONAL.
IT DEPENDS TREMENDOUSLY ON
MARKET POWER, AND LOBBYING
POWER.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE WAYS TO GET
MUCH BETTER RESULTS, WE NEED
WHAT IN THE LINGLE IS CALLED
RATIONAL DRUG PRICING.
WHICH EXPLICITLY TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT THE ROAD INCENTIVES
AND THE ACCESS ISSUES.
THE U.S. SYSTEM RIGHT NOW SAYS,
WE WILL BASICALLY GO OUT AND
DISCOVER SOMETHING AND THEN YOU
HAVE 20 YEARS OF MONOPOLY, DO
WHAT YOU WANT.
THAT SYSTEM UNDER ANY
THEORETICAL CONCEPTUAL TERMS
CAN HARDLY BE WHAT WE CALL
SECOND-BEST, IT CANNOT BE THE
RIGHT DESIGN, THERE ARE BETTER
MORE RATIONAL WAYS TO KEEP THAT
BALANCE.
ONE WAY BY THE WAY IS PUBLIC
FUNDING.
AND OPEN LICENSING OF THE
MEDICINES.
THIS COMPANY THAT I
PARTICULARLY DESPISE, GILEAD,
FOR MANY REASONS I DESPISE THE
DAILY PEOPLE TO DIE.
I DESPISE THEY KEEP THE PROFITS
ABROAD IN TAX HAVENS.
IN A COMPLETE TAX GIMMICK.
I BASICALLY DESPISE THAT THEY
DON'T DO ROAD  ALMOST AT ALL.
I WON'T GO INTO IT.
ANYWAY, WE'RE NOT GETTING THE
BEST OF THIS, WE'RE GETTING A
LOT OF WHAT IS CALLED ME TOO
INNOVATION MEANING JUDGMENT IS
AMOUNT OF  DUPLICATION OF ROAD
EFFORTS BECAUSE IT'S ALL
DESIGNED IN A PRETTY IRRATIONAL
WAY  TO CHASE HIGH MONOPOLY
PROFIT MARGINS, NOT TO CHASE
SOCIAL MEANS.
LET ME JUST SAY A LOT OF GOOD
CONSIDERATIONS, A GOOD SENIOR
THESES, A GOOD PHD
DISSERTATION, MANY TRADE-OFFS,
BUT WE'RE NOT EVEN CLOSE TO
GETTING THOSE TRADE-OFFS RIGHT
RIGHT NOW.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN CLOSING, LET ME THINK
DR.TEDROS  AND PRESIDENT LEE C.
BOLLINGER  IN THEIR ABSENCE.
WE CERTAINLY KEPT THEM.
AS I HAVE YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE WORLD
LEADERS FORM.
AND OTHERS FOR HELPING US SET
UP SUCH A COMPLEX EVENT.
AND TO ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
INTEREST IN GLOBAL HEALTH AND
SUPPORTING THE W.H.O..
AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
ADVANCING GLOBAL HEALTH.
I WISH YOU A GOOD
NIGHT.[APPLAUSE]